la séance est ouverte le contrenduit
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué il n'y a pas
d'observation le procèsverbal est adopté
sous les réserves d'usage mes chers
collègues contte tenu du nombre
d'amendements déposés sur la proposition
de loi instituant des mesures
judiciaires de sûreté applicable aux
condamnés terroristes et renforçant la
lutte antiterroriste nous pourrions en
accord avec les commissions concernées
et le gouvernement et après concertation
avec les groupes siéger éventuellement
ce soir afin de terminer l'examen des
textes inscrits à notre autre du jour
nous pourrions toutefois poursuivre nos
débats jusqu'à 21h s'il apparaissait
possible de TER terminer l'examen de ces
texes sans suspendre y a-t-il des
observations il est ainsi décidé
j'informe le Sénat qu'une candidature
pour siéger au sein de la commission
d'enquête sur l'impact du narcotrafic en
France et les mesures à prendre pour y
remédier a été publié cette candidature
sera ratifié sur la présidence si la
présidence n'a pas reçu d'opposition
dans le délai d'une heure prévue par
notre
règlement la parole est à Madame
Nathalie Goulet pour un rappel au
règlement oui monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues mon rappel au règlement et sur
l'article 29 de notre règlement Mohamed
robobadlou ce nom vous dit probablement
rien c'est un jeune iranien qui a été
pendu hier soir il a été pendu hier soir
pour avoir manifesté dans le mouvement
femme vie liberté il fait partie des
très nombreuses victimes je voulais
simplement dire que notre Sénat avait
voté de de résolutions une avec la la
commission des affaires européennes
l'autre avec la commission des affaires
étrangères que j'avais déposé avec mon
groupe de même que François patria et le
sien que cette proposition de résolution
visait plusieurs sanctions et il y a un
lien avec le débat que nous allons avoir
tout à l'heure sur le
terrorisme le rapporteur et les
commissions ont trouvé qu'il n'était pas
temps de mettre et d'inscrire les
Gardiens de la révolution sur la liste
des organisations terroristes depuis il
y a eu le 7 octobre
et la contribution de la République
islamique au pogrom orchestré par le
Hamas depuis il y a eu les attaque en
mer Rouge et la contribution de la
République islamique au travail de
destruction de la stabilité des
outils le moment est peut-être venu
monsieur le Président de remettre ces
deux résolutions votées par nos deux
commissions à l'ordre du jour pour
envisager des sanctions à l'égard de la
République islamique d'Iran dont je vous
rappelle euh qu'elle préside la
commission des droits de l'homme de
l'ONU et je ne sais vraiment pas
monsieur le Président dans quel monde
nous vivons
merci acte est donné de ce rappel au
règlement l'ordre du jour appppelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
instituant des mesures judiciaires de
sûreté applicaes au condamnés
terroristes et renforçant la lutte
antiterroriste présenté par notre
collègue le Président Monsieur François
Noël buffet
[Applaudissements]
merciés monsieur le Président messsieur
les ministres monsieur le rapporteur
chers collègues la proposition de loi
relative aux mesures judiciaires de
sûreté applicable au condamnés
terroristes et à la lutte antiterroriste
que nous vous présentons est aujourd'hui
nous le semble-t-il indispensable c'est
tout d'abord le maintien de la menace
terroriste un niveau très élevé et à
l'évolution de ces formes qui la rend
indispensable les récents attentats
d'aras et de birakeim ont
malheureusement révélé notre
vulnérabilité face à ces attaques
d'autant plus difficile à combattre
qu'elles sont désormais perpétrées par
ce que l'on qualifie de loup solitaire
dans les deux cas nous nous sommes nous
nous trouvons en effet en présence
d'individus isolés qui ne sont jamais
qui ne se sont jamais rendu dans la zone
sirro-irakienne et danst l'action n'est
pas soutenue par un réseau djihadiste
organisé ces réseaux ont d'ailleurs tiré
toutes les conséquences de cette
évolution en recentrant leur action sur
l'endoctrinement directement sur notre
sol d'individus incités à commettre des
actes de terrorisme via les réseaux
sociaux en l'état du droit il est
particulièrement ardu pour les services
de surveiller efficacement ces individus
qui se sont souvent radicalisés en ligne
et dont le passage à l'acte est
imprévisible il se situe par ailleurs
dans un angle mort du droit pénal
jusqu'au jour de leur passage à l'acte
puisque vous le savez le recel
d'apologie de terrorisme n'est aujourd
aujourd'hui pas sanctionné
l'intensification de la problématique
des sortants de prison contribue
également à ce maintien de la menace à
un niveau élevé les chiffres sont sans
appel depuis 2018 486 détenus islamistes
sont sortis de détention selon la DGSI
soit environ 50 % restent engagé dans
une idéologie radicale cette dynamique
ne va aller qu'en s'accentuant avec près
de 70 libérations programmé pour les
deux prochaines années et surtout les
premières remises en liberté d'individus
condamnés pour des faits de terroristme
a de lourdes peines nous pouvons donc
pas éluder non plus la question des
mineurs radicalisés qui prend chaque
année un peu plus d'ampleur je ne
donnerai qu'un seul exemple en 2023 19
mineurs ont été déférés pour association
de malfaiteurs en vue d'une entreprise
terroriste il s'agit du 3è total le plus
élevé depuis 2012 les services
constateent par ailleurs une évolution
préoccupante des profils avec des
individus plus jeunes et présentant des
projets d'attentat relativement aboutis
dans ce contexte
propice au débordement en tout genre
nous devons donc agir comme nous l'avons
toujours fait au Sénat à la fois avec
sans froid mais aussi avec
responsabilité sans renoncer bien sûr à
notre traditionnel rôle de gardien des
libertés publiques soyons clair par ce
texte nous ne voulons pas une une
révolution de la législation
antiterroriste cela par serait
d'ailleurs peu judicieux voire dangereux
à 6 mois d'une échéance telle que celle
des Jeux Olympiques notre approche est
beaucoup plus pragmatique et j'insiste
sur ce point nous appuyons ivement sur
les retours d'expérience et les besoins
exprimés par les acteurs de terrain
judiciaire comme administratifs il
s'agit de gommer les imperfections les
lacune du cadre législatif actuel en
d'autres termes nous entendons dans le
strict respect des libertés publiques
donner à nos forces de sécurité tous les
moyens juridique nécessaire au combat
efficace contre les nouvelles
expressions de menace terroriste le
premier volet de nos propositions de loi
de notre proposition de loi rénuve tout
d'abord le régime des mesures
judiciaires de sûreté appliqu au
terroristes sortant de détention c'est
en effet peut dire que la mesure de
prévention de la récidive terroriste
récemment mise en place n'a pas
tellement abouti elle n'a pas abouti
d'ailleurs elle n'a peut-être elle n'a
pu être mise en place qu'à la seule
reprise tant les critères de son
édiction on sont déconnecté de la
réalité des profils observés sur le
terrain nous avons donc souhaité
réintroduire une mesure hybride déjà
votée par deux fois dans cet hémicycle
mant suivant mant suivi et surveillance
judiciaire et au critères de éoncé plus
souple de la même manière la proposition
de loi étant le champ d'application de
la rétention de sûreté en raison de
troubles psychiatriques grave aux
criminels terroristes et crée un nouveau
régime de rétention de sûreté réservé
aux condamnés terroristes encore engagés
dans une idéologie radicale l'objectif
est simple éviter à tout prix les
sorties sèches comme l'ont dit je met ça
entre parenthèses bien sûr de condamnés
terroristes n'ayant pas renoncé à leur
projets mortifère
le deuxième volet de notre proposition
de loi prend à bras le corp la question
de la prise en charge des mineurs
radicalisés autour d'un principe
cardinal l'accompagnement autant que
nécessaire la sanction dès que
nécessaire c'est pourquoi les
dispositions de l'article 3 renforce
l'Arsenal à disposition des juges des
enfants dans les dossiers à caractère
terroriste en étendant les possibilités
de placement sous contrôle judiciaire en
centre éducatif fermé d'assignation sous
Brasset électronique ou de détention
provisoire sur le volet accompagnement
notre proposition de loi reprend
notamment une proposition qui avait déjà
été formulée en 2017 je vous rappelle
par nos collègues madame Esther Benbassa
et Madame Catherine trodely qui pour
éviter les ruptures de prise en charge à
la majorité autorise une poursuite de la
prise en charge de ces jeunes par la PGJ
le troisème volet de notre proposition
entend mettre en adéquation la
législation antiterroriste au nouveaux
modes opératoire observés sur le terrain
pour se faire nous nous estimons
incontournable l'introduction d'une
nouvelle forme de délit de recelle
d'apologie de terrorisme d'une peine
complémentaire de bannissement numérique
et d'interdiction de paraître autonome
des mesures individuelles de contrôle
administratif et de surveillance tous
ces instruments redonneront de notre
point de vue au service des marges de
manœuvre face à des individus
objectivement très dangereux mais qui ne
peuvent en l'état du droit faire l'objet
de poursuite pénale en amont de leur
passage à l'acte la régulation de
l'accès à l'espace numérique des
condamnés terroristes est également une
mesure de bon sens tant les réseaux
sociaux sont désormais et pas seulement
dans ce domaine le premier vecteur de
radicalisation enfin notre proposition
ajuste plusieurs dispositifs
antiterroristes qui a l'épreuve de la
pratique présente des limites
opérationnels c'est le cas de la
procédure d'autorisation d'achat de
fourniture sous pseudonyme dont les
lourdeurs actuelles limitent
singulièrement l'efficacité des services
je pense également à la modernisation
des critères permettant la dissolution
administrative des associations ou
groupements de fait à ce stade je
voudrais remercier Marc Philippe dobress
rapporteur de ce texte pour l'important
travail qu'il a réalisé devant la
commission et dont il vous dira dans
quelques instants quels sont les les les
résultats je crois que nous partageons
tous ici le même objectif et nous
pouvons nous en réjouir la commission
des lois et le Sénat dans son ensemble a
toujours répondu présent lorsqu'il
s'agissait de réformer les la
législation antiterroriste il est vrai
que nous sommes parfois hés il faut le
dire à la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel et que les conditions de
l'équilibre à tenir ne sont pas toujours
aisés à discerner tenir la ligne de
crête entre proportionnalité des mesures
et efficacité de la lutte antiterroriste
requiert naturellement d'unir nos
efforts c'est pourquoi nous avons tenu à
impliquer au maximum les acteurs de
terrain pour être au plus près de leurs
besoins et à prendre en compte dès que
cela était possible j'insiste dès que
cela est était possible de tous les
indices laissés par le Conseil
constitutionnel dans ses décisions
antérieures enfin je voudrais pour
terminer mes chers collègues vous dire
que ce texte arrive dans un contexte où
la gravité des enjeux est avérée chacun
le sait ici c'est à longueur de journal
télévisé ou d'événements dramatiques que
nous pouvons le constater l'intensité de
la menace terroriste mais le ministre de
l'Intérieur me démentira pas bien
évidemment et son son évolution nous
impose de rester unis et de prendre
collectivement nos responsabilités c'est
ce que nous essayons de faire avec ce
texte il s'inscrit dans une temporalité
particulière au-delà de l'arsenal
juridique qui vise à renforcer les
dispositifs du droit positif il
s'inscrit dans la préparation en tous
les cas l'arrivée prochaine d'un
événement mondial considérable en France
que sont les Jeux Olympiques et les jeux
paralmpiques naturellement ça ne
suffirait pas comme seul argument mais
ces outilslà sont absolument nécessaires
pour permettre à nos services de mener à
bien la mission qui est la leure alors
il me restera bien sûr à redire que Marc
Philippe d'bress a apporté des
corrections a même supprimé des articles
considérant que il n'était pas opérant
ce que j'en conviens était parfaitement
légitime mais je voudrais indiquer
messieurs les ministres que sur ce texte
il serait tout de même important car je
crois que j'espère que vous le direz
nous partageons en grande majorité les
objectifs et les moyens qui sont mis en
place nous puissions avoir urgence dans
le cadre du travail
législatif effectivement il me semble
que nous aurions tous intérêt et c'est
un intérêt collectif bien partagé et
bien compris à ce que ce texte puisse
être mise en place le plus rapidement
possible en tous les cas avant les
événements de l'été qui se présente car
sans vouloir mettre de pression sur qui
que ce soit il serait quand même dommage
que nous puissions pas bénéficier des
projets et des moyens qu'il propose pour
protéger l'ensemble de ceux qui veulent
venir sur le territoire ou qui ont sur
le territoire pour profiter de
l'ensemble de ces manifestations mais
pas seulement et pour les protéger
encore mieux du risque terroriste don
nous savons qu'il est plus qu'avéré et
qu'il est permanent merci à vous
merci la parole est à Monsieur Marc
Philippe doubress rapporteur de la
commission des lois pour 10
minutes monsieur le Président messieurs
les ministres monsieur le président de
la commission des lois
mes chers
collègues François Noël buffet vient de
le dire nous examinons aujourd'hui une
PPL qui institue des mesures judiciaires
de sûreté applicables au condamnés
terroristes et qui renforce la lutte
antiterroriste qui a été déposée par le
président de la commission des lois mais
aussi par le Président retaillot et par
le président
Marseille
évidemment que les tragiques attentats
d'aras et de birakeim ont nourit la
réflexion pour essayer essayer de de
d'apporter des réponses plus
adaptées cette proposition de loi notre
président de la commission des lois
vient de le dire vise à combler
plusieurs trous dans la raquette
plusieurs lacunes de la législation
pénale en vigueur et à octroyer au
pouvoir public les moyens judiciaires
administratif indispensable à une lutte
antiterroriste
efficace sur le fond la commission des
lois accueille évidemment favorablement
ce texte qui reprend des dispositions
déjà votées par le Sénat et a été comme
j'ai pu constater au cours de mes
auditions le fruit d'une réflexion
approfondie nourrie des observations et
propositions des acteurs de terrain de
la lutte
antiterroriste nous avons d'ailleurs à
plusieurs reprises au cours des trois ou
quatre dernières années déjà abordé ces
sujets au sein de notre commission et
déjà fait des propositions qui allaient
dans le même sens ce texte a le mérite
de la cohérence en fait en effet le
législateur a renforcé l'arsenal
antiterroriste au cours des dernières
années mais s'est concentré le président
buffet l' dit sur les menaces
exogène sans anticiper le fait que
euh nous nous concentrions jusqu'ici sur
la répression et le régime des peines et
non plus sur le suivi à l'issue de
l'exécution de la peine alors que nous
savons bien que
les personnes qui sortent de prison sont
le procureur antiterroristei lui-même
des menaces potentielles pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux aujourd'hui la menace
terroriste est donc devenue endogène
elle a un caractère plus imprévisible
les attaques sont ne sont plus perpétrés
par par des groupes armés mais par des
individus solitaires qui ne bénéficient
pas de l'appui de réseaux djihadistes
très organisés mais qui se sont
radicalisés sur les réseaux sociaux et
ont recourt le plus souvent des armes
blanches en vent libre nous sommes donc
dans une situation peu satisfaisante les
individus condamnés pour des faits
terroristes sont aujourd'hui les plus
suivis en détention y compris sur le
plan psychiatrique mais les moins
accompagnés au moment de leur libération
ces loups solitaires qui sont désormais
l'écrasante majorité des profil suivi
par les services de renseignement y
compris les mineurs adoptent des
comportements et des modes opératoires
qui sont mal appréhendés par le droit
pénal autoradicalisation en ligne
détention de centaines d'images de crime
et d'apologie du terrorisme et cetera et
cetera évidemment que l'arsenal
législatif est déjà très important pour
autant comme me l'ont indiqué les
acteurs judiciaaires et administratifs
compétent et dans une
large quasi unanimité les outils tant
judiciaires qu'admin ratif sont
incomplets inadaptés à l'enjeu et le
contexte que nous allons connaître dans
notre pays évidemment ne fait que
renforcer l'acquité de ces problèmes la
PPL soumise à l'examen de notre haute
assemblée n'entend pas bouleverser les
équilibres construits au cours des
dernières années elle poursuit
l'objectif principal de consolider cet
édifice juridique de remédier aux
lacunes que je viens de citer qui sont
apparu à la lumière des récents
attentats et évidemment que les
dispositions initiales de la proposition
de loi présenté par par le président
buffet requiert pour la grande majorité
notre
assentiment avec l'ensemble des acteurs
de la lutte antiterroriste auditionné
nous partageons la euh la conviction de
la nécessité de corriger certaines
dispositions pénales pour en améliorer
l' l'efficacité l'opécialité et euh nous
apportons une attention particulière à
un équilibre entre efficacité
opérationnalité des mesures et garantie
des droits et libertés
constitutionnelles c'est donc un
équilibre harmonieux pesé au trébucher
qui fait que euh nous aboutissons à un
texte et que évidemment je donnerai en
séance des avis défavorables à tous les
amendements qui veulent supprimer un
article ou une partie d'un article parce
que c'est un équilibre tout à fait euh
difficile à trouver et que je pense nous
avons réussi à trouver en liaison avec
les acteurs s'agissant des mesures
judiciaires de sûreté que vient
d'évoquer le président buffet nous avons
apporté trois évolutions
compte tenu du bilan non concluant du
déploiement de la mesure de prévention
de la récidive terroriste une seule
personne condamnée il est indispensable
de garantir son adéquation au profil des
individus concernés lainfraction
d'association de malfaiteurs terroristes
était déjà très exigeante là les
critères de dangerosité de la mesure la
rendent quasiment inapplicable c'est
pourquoi nous avons reformulé et visé
une probabilité élevée de récidive et
une adhésion avérée à une idéologie ou à
des thèses incitant à la commission
d'actes de tororis plutôt qu'une
probabilité très élevée et une adhésion
persistante à ces idéologies pour
garantir la proportionnalité de la
mesure et éviter de fragiliser les
services secrets nous yons fort insisté
ils ont raison de fragiliser les
micasses les existantes nous avons
contrebalancé cet élargissement par
l'ajout de plusieurs garanties en
renforçant le volet de réinsertion et
d'accompagnement de la mesure en
permettant au juges d'application des
peines de prononcer une injection de
soins pour certains profils et nous
avons exclu du contenu de la mesure les
trois mesures de surveillance
particulièrement attentatoires aux
liberté que sont l'interdiction de
paraître en certains lieux l'obligation
d'établir son domicile en un lieu donné
et l'interdiction de porort d'une arme
qui sont par ailleurs visé par toute une
série d'autres dispositifs en
particulier qui concern les micas de la
même manière la Commission a limité le
champ des mesures de rétention de sûreté
au seuls condamnés pour des crimes
terroristes à des peines supérieures à
15 ans de prison sur le volet
administratif nous avons souhaité
maintenir le caractère obligatoire d'une
autorisation judiciaire préalable pour
les opérations d'achat effectué par des
enquêteurs sous pseudonymes tout en
aménageant les modalités de sa
délivrance lorsque les produits sont
licites par ailleurs par ailleurs nous
avons choisi de substituer à
l'interdiction de paraître dans les
transports en commun dans le cadre de la
micas une interdiction de paraître
autonome mais moins attentatoire aux
liberté qui sera à mon avis plus facile
à mettre en œuvre notamment dans la
perspective des Jeux Olympiques enfin en
matière de dissolution des associations
et des groupements il nous a paru plus
opportun de consacrer dans la loi la
récente définition de la provocation
telle qu'énoncée par le Conseil d'État
est d'instituer un régime de dévolution
des biens des associations etant fait
l'objet d'une telle procédure pour faire
échec à leur stratégie de revente de
leurs biens en matière pénale la
Commission s'est attachée à renforcer la
cohérence judiciaire du texte améliorer
la pénalisation de certains
comportements particulièrement dangereux
raison pour laquelle nous avonsécrit
l'infraction réprimant la la détention
de contenu apologétique afin de
l'entourer d'une série de garanties pour
en assurer la
constitutionnalité nous avons donc
restreint le champ d'application par
deux moyens d'une part en introduisant
un critère de gravité restreint ne
sanctionnant que la détention des
contenus les plus graves d'autre part en
le complétant d'un élément intentionnel
pour que la l'infraction ne puisse être
constituée qu'à condition que l'adhésion
de l'auteur à un ou plusieurs crimes
terroristes soit manifeste nous avons
ainsi d'ailleurs tiré les conséquences
d'une censure du Conseil
constitutionnelle qui portait sur la une
création juris prudentielle qui ne
venait pas du Sénat et qui proposait une
interprétation extensive de ce délit tel
n'est pas notre choix en outre et je
conclus par la forte des propositions
des acteurs judiciaaires administratifs
nous avons rajouté des mesures
additionnelles l'intégration au délit
d'apologie du terrorisme de la diffusion
de contenu apologétique sur les réseaux
privés de communication dans certains
cas de figure l'obligation d'information
du procureur de la République en cas de
demande de changement de nom d'une
personne condamnée pour des crimes à
caractère terroriste et le renforcement
des informations communiqu au préfet
s'agissant de soins délivrés sans leur
consentement à des personnes
radicalisées ou aux autorités
académiques ou scolaires s'agissant de
personnes scolarisé étant mise en examen
ou condamné pour une infraction
terroriste enfin tenant compte des
observations de plusieurs collègues sur
certains points je vous proposerai
quelques amendements qui visent à
consolider les avancées déjà votées en
commission des
lois et par ailleurs j'ai revu la la
notion d'inconduite notoire en prenant
en compte les observation pertinente de
plusieurs de nos collègues l'intention
du procureur antiterroriste j'y
reviendrait dans le débat était
pertinente mais la formulation était
inadapté je l'ai donc changé nous allons
donc proposer un amendement
systématisant la formation des
procureurs en cas de demande de
changement de N d'un condamné tororis
nous donnerons un avis favorable à
plusieurs amendements notre collègue
jacqueseline stage brigot qui vise à
accélérer les procédures devant la
commission d'expulsion ou à garantir le
maintien en centre de rétention
administrative de tout étranger mise en
cause pour des fait de terrorisme enfin
nos collègues Hervé Marseille et
Nathalie Goulet ont proposé des avancées
contre à la lutte contre le financement
du terrorisme et la sécurisation moyenne
technologie nouvelle des grands
événements nous y donnerons des avis
favorables pour finir et pour conclure
je souhaite rappeler comme le disait à
l'instant le président buffet que face
au défi du terrorisme le Sénat a
toujours fait preuve de responsabilité
dès 2014 la Commission avait pris
l'initiative de plusieurs évolutions
législatives qui ont permis de renforcer
considérable arsenal pénal mais toujours
dans le strict respect des libertés
individuelles c'est ce même état
d'esprit qui doit aujourd'hui nous
guider et nous amener collectivement
approuver ce texte pour doter les
pouvoirs publics des nouveaux moyens
adaptés à la prise en charge des
nouveaux visages de la menace terroriste
qui est une priorité chacun sait pour la
sécurité des Français merci de votre
attention monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est à Monsieur
Géral ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outres
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des saut ch Éric monsieur le président
de la commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs d'abord une bonne année à
chacune et à chacun d'entre vous une
bonne année au Sénat monsieur le
Président partisan d'une haine sans
espoir partisan d'un sans espoir c'est
ainsi en effet Monsieur gardessau
qu'André malerud décrivait au fil de ses
romans et de ses écrits le point commun
des divers visage du
terrorisme expliquant également dans les
conquérrences cette évidence que la
réussite d'une action terroriste dépend
de la police qu'elle trouve en face
d'elle c'est tout l'objet de la
proposition nois monsieur le président
de la commission des lois que vous nous
présentez de faire échouer les actions
terroristes parce que nous sommes bien
préparés plus particulièrement dans le
contexte d'une menace dont l'actualité
s'est à nouveau révélée douloureuse pour
notre pays et pour le monde
occidental pour que vous puissiez en
toute connaissance de cause légiférer et
débattre pour que cette loi puisse
utilement compléter notre dispositif un
mot si vous me le permettez de l'état de
cette menace terroriste au moment où
nous vous
parlons cette année est particulière
durant lesquel la France va accueillir
les Jeux olympiques et parolympiques ce
qui lui arrive une fois par
siècle
des également des cérémonies
d'anniversaire du débarquement 80e
anniversaire du débarquement de
Normandie et de Provence et gardant sur
notre sol les grands événements qui
rassemblent et qui permettent
malheureusement des actes de terreur
parce que télévisé parce que
symbolique la menace terroriste demeure
donc très élevée sur notre sol et depuis
1 an et demi je ne cessa de le dire au
français depuis 2012 la France a subi 25
attaques terroristes qui ont causé 273
morts et des centaines de
blessés depuis que j'ai l'honneur d'être
ministre de l'Intérieur voilà quasiment
4 ans désormais 12 attentats djihadistes
ont été déjoués six liés à l'ultra
droite et à l'ultra
gauche quant aux 10 derniers attentats
perpétrés en France depuis 2020 ils ont
causé la mort de 11 personnes et en ont
blessé 16
autres vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
l'année 2023 fut particulièrement
meurtrière en effet après 19 mois sans
attentat un radicalisé assassiné
sauvagement un enseignant à haras le 13
octobre dernier et le 2 décembre un
partisan de l'État islamique a tué un
passant dans le quartier du Pont de
birakem à
Paris cette récente vague d'attentat n'a
pas épargné l'Europe et plus
particulièrement la Belgique le 16
octobre dernier dans le contexte nous le
savons propice au passage à l'acte du
conf
israélo-palestinien qui déclenche nous
le savons un certain nombre de
réactions à travers le monde et parmi la
menace en deogè en
particulier la menace actuelle qui est
caractérisée par des élément qui oblige
une grande vigilance et d'abord vous
l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur une
menace
endogène parmi
nous cela veut dire que ce sont souvent
des Français ou des étrangers qui sont
depuis longtemps sur notre sol inspirés
ou influencés par la propagande
djihadiste qui sont les plus enclins à
passer à
l'acte des terroristes de l'Intérieur
agissent souvent de leur propre chef et
depuis 2018 sont très autonome vis-à-vis
des mouvements terroristes connus
changement radical par rapport à ce que
nous connaission jusqu'à
présent quelques petits faits qui
cependant divergent depuis un an on
assiste un regain d'affiliation
explicite à des organisations
terroristes extérieures comme l'état
islamique autre fait nouveau vous l'avez
dit monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
Président si les terroristes sont
influencés par des contenus propagande
islamistes sur internet ils sont
également perméables à d'autres discours
de haine de violence et de négation des
valeurs
républicaines nous sommes passés de
lieux de radicalisation comme des lieux
de culte que nous avons largement fermés
à des lieux de radicalisation sur
Internet nous sommes passés
d'organisation associative financé par
l'extérieur à un
séparatisme évidemment plus
insidieux le succès des discours sur les
réseaux sociaux mobilise désormais des
profils extrêmement jeunes et bien
au-delà de la mouvance radicale
traditionnel pour vous donner un ordre
de grandeur plus de la moitié des
personnes impliquées dans un projet
d'attentat depuis 2021 avait moins de 20
ans le rajunissement et l'isolement des
individus que sur lequel les services de
renseignement et singulièrement la DGSI
doit faire face est un changement
profond dans les lous solitaires que
nous connaission jusqu'à
présent ces individus souvent isolés
socialement très connectés
virtuellement sont des jeunes scolarisés
qui complètent leur radicalisation par
des mauvaises fréquentations ou
malheureusement pour 30 % d'entre eux
psychiatriquement
instable la nécessité pour les services
de renseignement et de police de
recourir plus systématiquement à l'aide
de professionnel de la psychiatrie pour
les éclairer mieux évaluer les risques
et mieux prendre en charge les individus
n'est pas à renier il est évidemment un
défi au moment où la santé mentale en
France connaît par ailleurs des
difficultés
profondes mais la folie n'explique pas
tout et il est évident que les discours
se nourrissent d'abord de la thématique
dite du blasphème je mets des guillemets
li à la réédition des caricatures de
mahomé comme on l'a vu en France en
Suède et au Danemark ou à la thématique
de l'islamophobie je mets là aussi des
guillemets largement instrumentalisé et
fait basculer dans la violence des
individus plus difficilement détectable
obligeant tous les policiers et tous les
gendarmes à rester sur le qui
vivent les images de Gaza les
détournements les fake news mais aussi
les drames que con connaissent les
musulmans à travers le monde sont des
déclencheurs pour tous ceux qui en
France souhaitent trouver une excuse
pour passer à
l'acte monsieur le gardau vous le savez
mieux que personne le milieu carcéral
demeure aujourd'hui un défi pour la
sécurité nationale mais également le
terrorisme piloté de l'étranger qui
connaît un regain depuis 18
mois aujourd'hui nous pouvons penser que
les organisations islamiques comme
l'état islamique ou daesh n'ont pas les
moyens de reproduire des attentats comme
ceux de 2015 2016 mais ils en ont
l'intention et nous voyons refleurir des
publications des financements des
sélecteurs parfois des proxis qui
poussent leses services de renseignement
européens et singulièrement celui de la
France à de nouveau faire face également
à une menace
exogène vous le savez
et de nouveau la résurgence du conflit
israëlo-palestinien est très largement
exploitée par la propagande djihadiste
et les récentes publications de l'État
isamique a appelé à cibler Israël et les
Juifs partout sur les territoires
européens et notamment la France qui
accueille la première
communauté enfin au terroristes
islamistes de nos frontières au piloté
d'étranger s'ajoute des menaces
exacerbées par d'autres idéologies si le
terrorisme islamiste et le principal de
nos ennemis il n'est pas le
seul d'abord le terrorisme d'ultra
droite qui prospère depuis 2020 porté à
la fort par des réseaux subversifs et
des cellules dépendants de mouvements
mondiaux mais aussi des acteurs isolés
endogènes comme pour la menace
islamiste les
accélérationnistes mais aussi tous ceux
qui vivent dans le monde survivaliste et
particulièrement préoccupant et voilà
une ultra droite très armée beaucoup
plus que le reste de la
population très connecté grâce à des
relais sur internet mais également
évidemment avec une instrumentalisation
des crises internationales et nous
pensons bien sûr au conf israpalestinien
mais des gens de retour de zone déjà du
conflit
ukrainien la menace d'ultragauche existe
elle aussi
l'IER serait une erreur contre la
vérité pour l'instant il y a eu en effet
moins de projets d'attentat émanant de
l'ultra gauche que de l'ultra droite
mais personne n'est à l'abri de
militants ultraviolents qui se
revendique d'une gauche radicale pour
faire usage la violence et qui se
rapproche à très brve échéance du
terrorisme déjà sur la voie publique
l'ultragauche instrumentalise
régulièrement des manifestations et fait
feu de toute cause sociale ou
environnementale le risque d'un passage
à l'acte terroristme d'ultra gauche
n'est pas théorique mais bien avéré par
les services de renseignement comme une
opération de la DGSI a su montré l'année
dernière
dernière voici l'état de la
menace principalement
islamiste mais aussi d'ultra droite et
deain peut-être d'utra gauche vous
connaissez son ampleur sa nature et ses
objectifs les services du ministère de
l'Intérieur et ses homologues sont
pleinement mobilisés et disposent depuis
2021 il est vrai d'un arsenal juridique
renforcé d'abord grâce à la loi relative
à la prévention des actes de terrorisme
et du renseignement de 2021 qui a permis
les fameux
silt qui depuis 2017 aussi permettent
une adaptation de l'information un
travail de de nos administrations et un
contrôle beaucoup plus fort contre tous
ceux qui veulent attaquer notre façon de
vivre nul doute que ces périmètres silt
et ces actions silt nous permettent de
faire face à de grands événements comme
le 31 décembre dernier à Paris où 1
million et demi de personnes se sont
rassemblés la Coupe du monde de rugby ou
la venue du Saint-Père à Marseille ce
sera évidemment le cas pour les rgion
olympique et
parallympique la loi confortant les
principes de la République appelée loi
séparatisme d'OT 2021 a permis de lutter
extrêmement efficacement contre le
réplic communautaire pour combattre avec
efficacité contre le djihadisme
d'atmosphère pour enendre le mot de Gil
kpel et qui favorise on le sait la
radicalisation et le passage à l'acte
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois je serais très heureux
d'ailleurs de vous présenter quand vous
le souhaiterez le bilan de cette loi qui
d'écoles fermées en lieu de culte qui
sont obligés de se transformer de
prêcheurs expulsés en contrôle continu
de commerce de médecine dite préventive
de nonsolarisation des enfants ou bien
sûr l'idologie radicale nous permet de
pouvoir lutter contre ceux qui atteintte
aux valeurs de la République la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur voté il y a un an donne de
service des moyens humains et financiers
au moment où nous avons doublé en un
mandat le budget de la D DGSI une DGSI
qui pourra compter jusqu'à 5000 agents à
la fin de l'année 2024 et 500 de plus
encore lorsqu'elle amènera aménagera en
2028 dans le site unique de
saintouin autre moyen de renforcer notre
action l'éloignement des étrangers en
situation irrégulièr irrégulièr inscrit
au fsprt les fameuses fiches s nous
avons expulsé un nombre inédit
d'étrangers radicalisés qui évolu qui
évolu alors jusqu'à présent sur notre
territoire ces expulsions ont
continuellement augmenté 999 étrangers
radicalisés ont été expulsés depuis 2017
131 dans la seule loi dans la seule
année 2023 et j'espère de tout cœur que
les dispositions de la loi immigration
qui seront je l'espère validé par le
Conseil constitutionnel nous permettra
de continuer ce travail
puisque'aujourd'hui tous ceux qui
peuvent être expulsés grâce à la loi le
sont nous attendons donc ces
dispositions législatives
supplémentaires nous sommes également
mobilisés pour la prise en charge
précoce des individus susceptibles de
commettre un attentat la seule desgsi
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs a
transmis près de 90 signalements de ce
type en 2023 dont plus de 40 pour fait
d'apologie du
terrorisme alors aujourd'hui la
proposition de loi que nous soumet
monsieur le rapporteur est soumise à la
discussion et vient donc compléter ses
dispositions et renforce la coordination
de tous les services autour du ministère
de l'Intérieur et la DGSI chef de fil
vous le savez de la lutte antiterroriste
sur le territoire national avec objectif
principal de préserver vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président l'équilibre
nécessaire dans une démocratie entre le
besoin de sécurité et la PR préservation
des
libertés je pense particulièrement aux
dispositions qui concernent le ministre
de l'Intérieur c'est-à-dire ceux du
titre
3 l'évolution du régime de l'enquête
sous pseudonyme pour mieux répondre aux
besoins de souplesse opérationnelle
exprimé par les services votre article 6
nous permettra à coup sûr de mieux
fonctionner l'interdiction de paraître
dans les lieux exposés un risque de
menaces grave ou terroriste et
particulièrement pertinent notamment
dans la perspective des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques
l'élargissement des motifs de
dissolution d'association et de
groupements de fait prévus par le code
de la sécurité intérieure permettrait de
ne pas laisser prospérer sur notre
territoire des structures qui appellent
à commettre des violences en groupe et
je crois que monsieur le rapporteur
s'est inspiré de dernière jurisprudence
du Conseil d'État enfin le
rétablissement d'un délit de détention
de contenu apologétique pourrait
reprendre un objectif que nous
recherchons depuis bien longtemps et que
le Parlement nous a main de fois refusé
merci au Sénat et à monsieur le
rapporteur même si je mesure que le
chemin qu'il reste à parcourir pour
éviter une censure du Conseil
constitutionnelle est
importante au-delà de formulations qui
pourront être corrigé aujourd'hui et
peut-être demain à l'Assemblée nationale
j'ai deux réserves principales monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur le Président dans
les dispositions initiales de votre
texte donc vous avez compris que je
partageis évidemment l'idée et le fond
la première c'est l'ajout d'une
circonstance aggravante au délit
d'apologie de provocation des actes du
terrorisme
lorsque ces propos sont tenus dans
l'exercice du lieu de culte ou dans un
lieu de culte par un ministre du culte
le Conseil d'État monsieur le rapporteur
vous le savez en effet déjà eu
l'occasion à mainte reprise de se
prononcer sur disposition notamment
similaire voulu par le gouvernement dans
son avis du 3 décembre 2020 sur le
projet dit séparatisme et considéré à
l'époque qu'il n'est pas souhaitable de
multiplier les particularités je cite de
la règle pénale en prévoyant pour des
infractions identiques des sanctions
différentes selon la situation de
l'auteur de infraction je rajoute
d'ailleurs que la loi de séparation des
aguises et de l'état prévoit un lieu
particulier qui est celui du lieu de
culte ou pour le droit pénal le fait de
s'en prendre à un ministre du culte ou à
un culte est aggravé en tant que victime
mais jamais en tant qu'auteur peut-être
monsieur le rapporteur pour avoir une
disposition qui sera utile évidemment au
travail des services serait-il de ce
fait plus prudent de ne pas exposer la
mesure un risque de censure
constitutionnelle et de suivre l'avis du
Conseil d'État de l'article 12 sur le
fond vous aurez compris que je vous
partage bien sûr votre
envie sur le fond il me semble que vous
prenez un grave risque vu que voilà
quelques mois seulement le Conseil
d'État s'est déjà exprimé sur cette
question ma deuxième réserve concerne
l'introduction d'une peine
complémentaire d'interdiction de
paraître dans les transports publics dès
lors qu'un individu aurait commis un
acte à caractère terroriste dans ce même
type de lieu à mon sens cette
disposition existe déjà dans le droit
elle est comprise dans l'interdiction
générale de paraître et je m'interroge
sur l'utilité à forcerie puisqu'un agent
de transport n'a pas accès au fichiers
des personnes recherchées dit FPR et que
le ministère de l'Intérieur n'a pas
prévu de laisser les agents de transport
accéder au
FPR d'abord parce qu'une partie des
agents de transport font parfois partie
de ce
FPR je veux donc dire ici à la
représentation nationale que si ces
dispositions sont utiles par principe
ell nous permettent par le droit actuel
d'y répondre il me semble que l'article
15 mériterait soit d'être supprimé soit
d'êtreécrit avec je l'espère la
possibilité pour tous les agents de
transport de bien se disposer des
besoins de sécurité auquel nous leur
demandons lorsque nous avons à la RATP
la SNCF et partout ailleurs des doutes
sur tel ou telle personnalité
sensible je veux terminer en saluant le
travail de la commission des Lois du
Sénat et les améliorations
substantielles rapporté par le
rapporteur de Bress en effet parmi les
avancé de votre rapport monsieur le
rapporteur je vois le fait qu'une
micasse ne soit pas suspendue pendant la
procédure d'appel pour éviter la disp i
de la personne surveillée ça me paraît
une bonne mesure la mesure qui donne au
préfet la possibilité de faire appel ou
de former un pouvoir en cassation pour
contester une ordonnance qui n'autorise
pas l'exploitation des données saisies
lors de la visite domiciliaire ce qui
vient rendre à la procédure un équilibre
entre les parties qui est
bienvenu le fait de permettre au préfet
dans lequel dans le département duquel
une personne suivie pour radicalisation
à caractère terroriste et au service de
renseignement de connaître certaines
informations est utile au suivi des
personnes placées en soin sans
consentement cette mesure est très utile
et par ailleurs avait été suggéré par le
Conseil d'État je le sais dans son avis
sur le décret portant application du
fameux traitement obsiweb celui que nous
avons créé avec le ministère de la Santé
pour le de suivi des personnes qui sont
atteints de maladie mentale autre ajout
très utile à nos yeux la modification
des critères permettant de prolonger la
durée de rétention en cras jusqu'à 180
jours pour l'étranger coupable de
provocation directe à des actes de
terrorisme elle s'inscrit parfaitement
dans la politique de fermeté que nous
souhaitions avoir et répond je crois au
débat qu'on a eu également pendant la
loi
immigration je veux aussi insister sur
l'intérêt qu'il y a d'introduire un
délit d'apologie du terrorisme aux
actions menées sur les réseaux privés de
communication lorsque ces réseaux à
raison de leur nature et de leurs
conditions d'accès du nombre de
personnes il accédant ou leur
appartenance ou non à une communauté
d'intérêt peuvent être assimilé à des
services de communication publique en
ligne mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs les réseaux sociaux
ségulièrement les messageries cryptés
qui s'apparentent par parfois des
réseaux sociaux les groupes télégram par
exemple sont désormais l'une des
difficultés du travail du ministère de
la Justice et les services de police je
soumets à la sagacité du rapporteur et
du Sénat le fait que adhérer à un groupe
télégram qui met des photos des vidéos
de viol d'enfants en ligne par exemple
qui trafique de la drogue en ligne par
exemple ou qui partage les contenu à
politique du terrorisme n'est pas une
infraction alors que nous savons tous
que lorsque des groupes sont suivis par
2000 5000 20000 30000 50000 personnes ce
qui est le cas dans certains endroits
notamment pour la drogue mais c'est
aussi le cas je le sais pour la
pédophilie et bien sûr pour les sujets
terroristes nous ne comprenons pas très
bien pourquoi nous pouvons continuer à
laisser faire un tel sujet et je veux
redire devant le Sénat monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président toute
la difficulté qu'ont les services de
renseignement aujourd'hui et les
services de police judiciaire de mettre
à la modernité les écoutes téléphoniques
classiques et il faut bien avouer que
les messages écryptés et par le fait que
par nature il n'y a pas de porte dérobé
pour y arriver si JIS dire comme une
écoute classique nous empêche de faire
notre travail contre le banditisme et
bien sûr contre le terrorisme sauf à
utiliser des moyens exorbitants que la
DGC seul peut mettre en place et qui ne
peuvent toucher que quelques personnes
enfin il faut saluer monsieur le garde
des saau la disposition destinée à
contrer si vous me le permettez les
effets indésirables de la loi dite vigal
dont je salue évidemment le rapporteur
en donnant au procureur de la République
non pas au pouvoir administratif la
possibilité en effet de s'opposer à la
demande de changement de nom en cas de
condamnation pour crime à caractère
terroriste je pense que c'est une mesure
de bon sens voilà monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs quelquesunes des
avancées que permet le texte que vous
proposez qui n'est certes pas la
révolution comme l'a dit monsieur le
Président mais une belle évolution pour
ce qui concerne les dispositions du
titre 3 du ministère de l'Intérieur pour
donner des moyens supplémentaires pour
se défendre contre le
terrorisme mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur je fais le vœu que nous
trouvions la rédaction la plus conforme
possible à nos textes constitutionnels
parce qu'il a urgence évidemment c'est
des grands événements qui a sans doute
poussé votre chambre à mettre à l'ordre
du jour ce texte à 106 jours de la
flamme olympique sur le territoire
hexagonal et à 200 jours de la cérémonie
d'ouverture que nous organisons tous les
3000 ans puisqu'on l'a jamais
fait merci la parole est à Monsieur
morti garde des sa ministre de la
Justice monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre de l'Intérieur et des outres
maèes cher Gérald monsieur le président
de la commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le terrorisme islamique est un
fléau contemporain de nos sociétés
occidentale et démocratique un fléau que
nous devons combattre évidemment de
toutes nos forces pour assurer la
sécurité de nos concitoyens et la
sauvegarde de nos
valeurs notre rôle à nous responsable
est d'être à la hauteur de ce combat et
c'est ce qu'attend de nous nos
compatriotes en France nous n'avons pas
à rougir
de ce que nous avons déjà fait je pense
que nous pouvons même nous féliciter
d'avoir l'un des dispositifs
antiterroristes les plus complets au
monde et depuis
1986 la France a en effet renforcé
considérablement son arsenal de
prévention et de répression du
terrorisme tous les actes de terrorisme
ont été érigé en infraction
autonome puni de peines
aggravé
ces infractions obéissent un régime
procédural
particulier caractérisé par la
centralisation des poursuites de
l'instruction ainsi que du jugement nous
avons également créé un régime
dérogatoire qui renforce
l'efficacité des enquêtes et
l'effectivité de l'exécution des peines
les aménagements et réduction des peines
sont ainsi strictement limités en outre
les auteurs d'infraction terroristes
font l'objet d'une prise en charge
pénitentiaire là encore spécifique je
vais même plus loin notre arsenal s'est
adapté aux évolutions de la menace
terroriste le Parlement a ainsi renforcé
notre dispositif en votant en 2019 la
création du parquet national
antiterroriste
vous avez chers parlementaires consacré
l'existence d'un parquet autonome
spécialisé
qui depuis a montré son
efficacité la proposition de loi que
votre assemblée est appelée à examiner
aujourd'hui propose d'apporter des
réponses complémentaires pour lutter
contre le terrorisme et la
radicalisation et je veux saluer le
travail du Président buffet dont
l'engagement sur ces questions n'est
plus à démontrer certaines dispositions
du
texte procèdent à des ajustements de
notre droit elles sont nécessaire et
disons-le bienvenu d'autres dispositions
apparaissent en revanche plus discutable
et nécessiterait que nous les
retravailonss ensemble quelques-unes
semblent en effet soulever des problèmes
de
constitutionnalité quelques autres
semblent soulever des problèmes
opérationnels car si notre système
repose sur un traitement spécifique des
procédures de terrorisme il demeure
évidemment respectueux de notre État de
droit j'ai depuis toujours la conviction
intime que ce qui distingue la
civilisation de la barbarie c'est la
règle de droit et contrairement à ce que
disent des
populistes de plus en plus nombreux
l'État de droit n'est pas un obstacle à
la lutte contre le terrorisme il en est
l'instrument et c'est pourquoi la lutte
contre la radicalisation doit reposer
sur un régime respectueux de la légalité
je pense que nous sommes tous d'accord
sur ce
point dans son œuvre normative le
législateur a toujours cherché à
concilier la spécificité qu'impose la
lutte contre une criminalité complexe
dont la finalité n'est rien d'autre que
l'effondrement de notre modèle sociétal
avec la défense des valeurs de notre
République et je suis convaincu que vous
avez à nouveau à l'esprit cet impérieux
besoin d'équilibre alors que nous
abordons ces débats cet
après-midi ce texte mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs propose tout
d'abord de créer des nouvelles mesures
judiciaires de sûreté applicable aux
personnes condamnées pour des actes de
terrorisme dont certains paraissent
présenter une certaine dangerosité alors
que leur peine arrivent à leur terme je
voudrais d'abord rappeler quelques
éléments
un travail important est réalisé dans
nos établissements pénitentiaires afin
de prévenir la radicalisation des
détenus et de freiner tout prosélitisme
délé
TER les services de mon ministère
travaillent pour assurer tant
l'évaluation que la prise en charge des
personnes condamnées pour des faits de
terrorisme présentant des signes de
radicalisation la remise en liberté de
détenus condamnés potentiellement
toujours radicalisés mais qui auraient
purgé leur peine est accompagné bien
évidemment de mesures de
surveillance depuis 2017 nous nous
sommes attachés à créer des dispositifs
novateurs et à améliorer les mesures
existantes notre droit comporte
désormais de nombreuses mesures
administratives et judiciaaires qui
permettent d'assurer le suivi des
condamnés pour des actes de terrorisme à
l'isue de leur
incarcération ces personnes peuvent
notamment faire l'objet d'un suivi
socio-judiciaire qui permet d'assurer
des mesures de contrôle de la personne
pendant une durée longue de 10 20 30 ans
ou toute la vie selon les cas cette
mesure particulièrement rigoureuse est
désormais obligatoire en matière de
terrorisme depuis la loi du 10 août 2020
ensuite une surveillance judiciaire peut
également être prononcée à la sortie de
la détention elle permet d'imposer des
oblig
aux personnes considérées comme
dangereuses la mesure judiciaire de
prévention de la
récidive et de réinsertion créé par la
loi du 30 juillet
2021 permet que la situation de certains
détenu soit examiné sur réquisition du
procureur de la République
antiterroriste par la
commission pluridisciplinaire des
mesures de sûreté après évaluation de
personnes concernées au sein du Centre
national d'évaluation des publics
radicalisé du centre pénitentiaire de
vandin
Leveille lorsque la décision judiciaire
prise ces personnes sont ainsi soumises
lors de leur remise en liberté à des
obligations et des interdictions elles
font l'objet d'un accompagnement
resserré non seulement sanitaire social
mais également éducatif psychologique ou
psychiatrique en outre toute personne
condam ané pour terrorisme apologie ou
provocation au terrorisme est inscrite
au fichier judiciaire national
automatisé des auteurs
d'infraction qui emporte notamment
l'obligation de déclarer son adresse de
signaler tout déplacement à l'étranger à
ces mesures judiciire vous le savez
s'ajoute des mesures administratives au
premier rang desquelles figure la micass
mesures individuelles de contrôle
administratif et de surveillance créé
par la loi dite silt d'octobre
2017 l'efficacité globale de ces
dispositifs repose à la fois sur leur
complémentarité et une parfaite
articulation entre autorité
administrative d'une part et autorité
judiciaire d'autre
part la proposition de loi envisage de
remplacer la mesure judiciaire de
prévention de la récidive terroriste et
de réinsertion par une nouvelles mesures
qui déjà avaient été proposé par le
Sénat en
2021 la rédaction proposée prévoit le
prononcer d'obligation et d'interdiction
similairire ou de même nature que celle
prévue par
l'imicas une telle superposition est de
nature à
fragiliser la légalité desmicass qui
serait prononcé à l'encontre des mêmes
personnes alors même qu'ell permettent
le prononcer d'obligation plus
rigoureuse c'est notamment le cas de
l'interdiction de ne pas fréquenter
certaines personnes le droit actuel
distingue clair
les finalités de la mesure
administrative par rapport à celle de la
mesure judiciaire la première étant
destinée à assurer la surveillance de la
personne alors que la seconde est
destinée à prévenir la récidive nous
considérons que la suppression de
dispositifs de sûreté la superposition
pardonnez-moi de dispositifs de sûreté
différents nuite à l'efficacité de
l'action de l'État prise dans ses
fonctions administratives et judiciaires
la proposition de loin propose également
une rétention de sûreté applicable à des
personnes qui ne souffle qui ne souffre
d'aucun trouble de la personnalité
médicalement constatée mais qui présente
une
dangerosité une telle mesure privative
de liberté fondée sur un soupçon d'ordre
criminologique serait je le pense
contraire à notre Constitution je
chhaite à cet instant appeler
l'attention de votre assemblée sur un
point particulier les mesures de sûreté
doivent respecter le principe résultant
de l'article 9 de la déclaration
1789 selon lequel la liberté ne saurait
être entravée par une rigueur qui ne
serait pas nécessaire et à plusieurs
reprises le Conseil constitutionnel est
venu rappeler la vigilance qui doit être
celle du législateur sur le caractère
adapté nécessaire et proportionner des
mesures restrictives de liberté
lorsqu'elles sont imposées à des
personnes ayant purgé leur
peine il ne faudrait pas laisser penser
que nous sommes prêts à instaurer une
quelconque forme de justice prédictive
qui est la négation de l'idée même de
justice puisqu'elle revient à condamner
sur un simple
soupçon dans le prolongement de mes
premières observations je veux
maintenant dire un mot sur
le délit de détention d'imag terroristes
qui figure dans le texte que vous allez
examiner dans ce cas précis un tel délit
a déjà été jugé contraire à la
Constitution la seule adhésion à une
idéologie
terroriste sans en faire l'apologie ne
suffit pas à caractériser une volonté de
commettre un acte terroriste votre
commission propose néanmoins d'élargir
la répression des apologies d'actes de
terrorisme lorsqu'elles sont commises
sur les réseaux privé c'est une mesure
qui va dans le bon sens car il ne fait
aucun doute que l'apologie du terrorisme
doit être sanctionné même si elle est
non publique je souhaite également
saluer le travail de la commission des
lois sur un certain nombre de mesures
qui apparaissent opportunes il s'agit
essentiellement des amélior apporté au
dispositif
d'micass et de celui relatif à
l'information des préfets concernant les
soins les soins psychiatriques d'une
personne
radicalisée plusieurs mesures concernant
le placement sous-bcelet électronique
des mineurs le contrôle judiciaire des
mineurs âgés de 13 à 16 ans la
possibilité de prononcer une peine en
audience unique la prolongation d'un
placement pénal avec suivi par la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
au-delà de 18 ans ou encore la
révocation du surcis probatoire et du
suivi sociau-judiciaire retiennent
également toute mon attention ces
mesures vont dans le bon sens et
pourront être améliorées par la suite
notamment sur le plan technique en
conclusion ce texte poursuitite à un
objectif louable nous devons néanmoins
être vigilant à respecter les exigences
constitutionnel je souhaite donc
vivement que ce texte puisse être
amélioré pour consolider un édifice déjà
robuste en matière de lutte contre le
terrorisme merci dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur GUID bénaroche pour 5 minutes
du groupe écologie solidarité et
territoire
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le président de
commission monsieur le rapporteur
messieurs les ministres d'abord je
m'excuse de euh je Seris peut-être un
peu chaotique parce que je ouais parce
qu'en fait je je j'ai la voix très
enroué je tousse beaucoup donc
excusez-moi s'il y a des j'arête pas
tousser dans les micros
euh monsieur buffet monsieur d'bress
monsieur duupiti monsieur darmanet en
fait ce qui est un peu paradoxal je
dirais que c'est qu'en écoutant les
débuts de chacune de vos interventions
c'està les constats que vous faites sur
la caractérisation aujourd'hui de la
menace terrorisme et du terrorisme en
fait je suis très proche de vos analyses
et je les partage assez et ce qui me
paraît paradoxal en fait pour être clair
alors je sais bien que le bid ou le bid
du proborti on quelques réserves à
certains des articles avec leur
souplesse et avec le leur diplomatie euh
mais cela étant dit en ce qui me
concerne la réalité honnêtement c'est
que je trouve que la grande majorité des
articles que vous proposez ne résolvent
même pas les problématiques que
vous-même avez défin avez posé et essayz
de résoudre par ce texte en fait mon
plus grand reproche à ce texte c'est
qu'on pourrait l'ajouter à un 1è texte
plutôt sécuritaire mais qui ne va pas
avoir de réel impact sur la résolution
des problèmes que vous souhaitez
euh toucher
voilà bien entendu je partage totalement
également ce ce qu'a dit le ministre euh
un état de droit éat d'État de droit et
comme l'a rappelé l'ancien commissaire
au droits de l'homme ou le le secrétaire
général des Nations unies nous devons
combattre sans relâche le terrorisme
bien entendu pour protéger les droits de
l'homme et en même temps en protégeant
les droits de l'homme nous nous
attaquons aux causes profondes du
terrorisme parce qu'une partie en fait
des solutions que vous auriez pu
proposer sont absente totalement de ce
de texte qui reste un texte qui ne nous
paraît pas une réflexion concertée ou
apaisée mais qui un texte qui vient se
joindre comme je l'ai dit une infl
législative ces dernières années bien
sûr la menasse terroriste existe elle
est forte elle est protéiforme vous vous
l'avez vous l'avez défini mais les
proposition porté par les auteurs sont
loin d'être à la hauteur de cet enjeu et
portent en elle des dérives sécuritaires
et une surcher répressive en fait
l'utilité la
constitutionnalité l'opérationnalité des
mesures et plus simplement son
efficacité nous paraissent absolument
pas démontré ni démontrabl les constats
portés par le rapporteur sur ce texte
sont pourtant réel et inquiétant
difficulté de prise en charge y compris
psychologique et psychiatrique des
condamnés terroristes à l'issue de leur
peine imprévisibilité croissante des
attaques terroristes par des loups
solitaires ou encore problématique de la
radicalisation croissante des mineurs
mais ce texte n répond pas et en
s'empilant sur notre arsenal contre le
terrorisme nourri de plus de 20 lois
depuis
1986 il ne nous paraît
qu'affaiblir il en a parlé un petit peu
notre ministre notre gardessau il ne
faut qu'affaiblir pour moi les principes
fondamentaux de notre droit notre gr
groupe a toujours porté une politique
claire dès la loi de confiance dans
l'institution judiciaire les réponses ne
peuvent uniquement consister à ronier
les droits de la défense ou sur la
capacité au juges de juger la prise en
charge et le suivi notamment
psychiatrique des condamnés terroristes
après leur peine ne peut se faire auprès
de la pression des garanties des j des
justiciables l'autoradicalisation ne
peut se giculer sans comprendre et
prendre en charge l'isolement sociales
et les pathologies parfois
psychiatriques des individus la
radicalisation des mineurs ne peut
s'appréhender uniquement par la
surveillance sans se préoccuper de
l'accompagnement nécessaire de ces
populations je rappellerai ce qu'a dit
la CNDH sur une notion d' conduite
notoire qui a été remplacée au dernier
moment dans le texte on en parlera tout
à l'heure la commission euh consultatif
des droits de l'homme déclaré que le
système judiciaire français se futete
sur un fait prouvé et non sur la
prédiction aléatoire d'un comportement
futur il faudrait éviter de tomber dans
ce travers elle s'inquiète donc de
l'instauration de mesures restrictives
de liberté reposant sur un fondement
aussi incertain source inévitable
d'arbitraire notre groupe se désor
également que rien ne soit fait pour
plus de prévention et d'accompagnement
de la radiculation particulièrement des
mineurs avec entre autrre le transfert
acté des mineurs radical is vers la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse en
lieu et place de la prise en charge par
l'aide sociale à l' force pourquoi ne
pas plutôt soutenir les départements
dans leur prise en charge de ces mineurs
une étude de l'IFER de 2018 démontrait
que la majorité des actes terroristes
étaient perpétré par des personnes sans
antécédents judiciaires la pauvreté
l'isolement social sont également des
facteurs propices à la radicalisation et
rien dans ce texte ne vient aborder ces
sujets aucune solution nous regrett
donc ce texte qui vise à renforcer la
lutte terroriste sans faire de
proposition sur la coopération
européenne ou internationale sur le
financement du terrorisme et la lutte
contre le rô plus que trouble de
certains pays disposant d'une puissance
régionale pour toutes ces raisons notre
groupe ne votera pas ce texte et a
déposé une dizaine d'amendements que
nous aurons l'occasion de
défendre merci chers collègues la parole
est à Monsieur LAN brossa du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste kanaki pour 5
minutes monsieur le Président Monsieur
le le garde des saau mes chers collègues
la lutte contre le terrorisme est une
priorité indiscutable et il est de notre
responsabilité collective de mettre en
place des dispositifs efficaces pour
assurer la sécurité de nos concitoyens
accomplir cette tâche complexe requiert
une exigence particulière celle d'être
collectivement vigilant à ne pas céder
au terrorisme à cet égard la société
française a résisté elle a refusé
jusqu'à présent et tant mieux de tomber
dans les pièges tendus par les
terroristes comme les États-Unis ont pu
le faire avec Guantanamo nous avons
collectivement fait le choix de ne pas
sacrifier notre État de droit cela doit
rester notre boussole en effet le
terrorisme tel un poison cherche sans
cesse à nous contraindre à changer de
modèle notre droit n'a pas été seulement
fait pour les temps calmes il a été fait
pour tous les temps dès lors lutter
contre le terrorisme c'est réfléchir sur
ce que peut notre État de droit pour
combattre légalement ceux qui balayent
toute forme de légalité sans succomber à
la tentation du dénis de l'indifférence
ou de la surenchère c'est là que le rôle
du politique est crucial il peut et doit
faire face au terrorisme en respectant
nos principes fondamentaux pour protéger
notre société et réparer les victimes la
vague d'attentat qu'a connu la France en
2015 dont le souvenir a été r avivé par
le procès des attentats de Charlie Hebdo
et de l'hyercacher a profondément marqué
notre pays elle a bouleversé
l'institution pénitentière et au-delà la
justice la politique pénale a depuis ces
événements connu un durcissement
considérable l'augmentation du nombre de
personnes incarcérées pour des affaires
en lien avec le terrorisme ont mis nos
prisions sous pression mais face à des
injonctions contradictoires
l'administration pénitentiaire peine à
donner un sens à leur prise en charge
dans le fond cette proposition de loi
qui traite principalement des personnes
sortant de prison doit nous interroger
considérons-nous ces personnes comme
définitivement irrécupérable notre
société fait-elle face à des causes
perdues qu'elle choisit indistinctement
de neutraliser le point aveugle de ce
texte est précisément la prison et la
mission de prise en charge assigné à
l'administration pénitentiaire à nos
yeux la répression seul ne peut être la
réponse complète à cette problématique
il faut s'attaquer aux causes profondes
du terrorisme en mettant en place des
politiques cohérentes de prise en charge
des détenus
radicalisés sur ce sujet l'heure n'est
pas aux querelles mais à l'action il est
impératif de professionnaliser le
travail autour de la radicalisation
celle-ci doit être abordée avec méthode
afin d'obtenir des résultats concret le
monde carcéral est le talon d'achile de
la société face à la radicalisation et
il manque considérablement de moyens
pour prendre à bras le corp ce problème
en outre la psychiatrie ne doit pas être
oubliée le cas de l'assaillant du pont
birakem à Paris présentant des troubles
psychiatriques et neurologiques souligne
l'importance de renforcer les moyens de
la psychiatrie de ville pour le suivi
des patients au profil complexe quant
aux mineurs ce texte renvoie la prise en
charge de certains d'entre eux à la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse et
semble ainsi louer son utilité nous nous
en félicitons mais je ne peux que faire
le lien avec la défense de notre groupe
lors des débats budgétaires de avec la
question de la hausse des moyens humains
de la PJJ or il se trouve que à l'époque
au moment du débat budgétaire la
majorité sénatoriale n'a pas souhaité
nous suivre sur ce point il n'est ici
pas seulement question d'évolution du
droit pénal mais également des moyens
donnés au services public pour
fonctionner correctement ce texte élut
donc un certain nombre de questions
essentielles et s'illustre à nos yeux
par ses manques à l'inverse il il se
distingue par ses ajouts ceux du
rapporteur notamment bien éloigné de
l'ambition initiale il y a de ce point
de vue-là un certain nombre de choses
qui ne peuvent manquer de nous inquiéter
des dispositions qui vont bien au-delà
de la question du terrorisme le texte
inclut des modifications sur les
dissolutions administratives qui ont
déjà été considérablement révisées par
la récente loi sur le séparatisme le
ministre de l'Intérieur le disait tout à
l'heure par le biais d'amendement il
nous est proposé de légalement définir
la provocation justifiant la dissolution
d'une association en outre il est
suggéré la création d'un régime de
transfert des biens des associations
dissoutes par ailleurs l'article le 6
ajuste les règles d'autorisation pour
les enquêteurs effectuant des achats de
produits légaux dans le cadre d'une
enquête sous pseudonyme enfin toujours
par le biais d'amendement il nous est
proposé que la notion je cite
d'inconduite notoire devienne un motif
de révocation d'un surcis probatoire et
d'un suivi sociau-judiciaire vous
conviendrez que nous sommes bien loin de
l'objectif assigner initialement à cette
proposition de loi pour toutes ces
raisons nous avons déposé un certain
nombre d'amendements et nous espérons
qu'il puisse être adopté afin de
modifier les éléments qui dans ce texte
nous préoccupent je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Monsieur
Michel
massé pour 5
minutes monsieur le Président Monsieur
le gardessau monsieur le rapporteur
chers collègues
cette proposition de loi
sénatoriale se veut être une réponse au
récents attentats terroristes qui ont
touché la
France les débats que nous allons avoir
vont certainement éclairer ce texte et
la direction que le Sénat veut donner
aux politiques publiques de la sécurité
pour nos
concitoyens nous allons revenir sur
chacun des articles et il n'y a pas lieu
au titre de la discussion générale
d'apposer un blanin ou une opposition de
principe aux mesures qui sont
proposées toutefois au nom du RDSE je
vis faire part de deux remarques à titre
liminire d'abord sur les raisons qui ont
motivé la rédaction de ce texte nos
concitoyens attendent des réponses de
l'État face aux attaques qui sont
commises sur notre sol et il est vrai
que la menace évolue elle est est
amplifié par l'indoctrinement progressif
rendu possible par les réseaux
numériques qui exacerbent les identités
et propage des idéologies
mortifères à cela il faut ajouter la
problématique très spécifique des
personnes détenu en France pour des
actes de terrorisme et qui devront
sortir de détenenstion très
prochainement c'est l'une des
préoccupations qui ont motivé cette
rédaction mais aussi l'islamisme radical
qui constitue toujours une menace
importante les services de renseignement
alert également sur la montée en
puissance la menace terroriste venant de
grosuscules
Fas fascisant mais aussi tout aussi
fascisant mais tout aussi
délétaire je sais que tous les groupes
du Sénat sont attachés à travailler
ensemble pour garantir la sécurité des
Françaises et des Français c'est un
impératif pour le
nous avons toujours été mobilisés
ensuite comme nombre de mes collègues je
me fais le porte-voie d'un appel à
l'équilibre les principes cardinaux de
notre droit pénal sont un héritage des
Lumières et de la Révolution la
proportionnalité et l'individualisation
des peines ou le principe selon lequel
on peut être condamné deux fois pour le
même fait on ne peut être cond deux fois
pour le même fait ne sont pas des
obstacles à une efficace ils sont au
contraire des protections de notre État
de droit et je reprends donc le collègue
spiner qui dit qui dit qui appelle notre
capital
moral le Sénat autrefois conservateur de
la Constitution ne doit voir le contrôle
de la loi par le Conseil constitutionnel
comme un empêchement mais comme un outil
de sauvegarde des droits et
libertés charge au débat que nous allons
tenir de trouver cet équilibre entre
liberté et sécurité qui ne deviennne pas
un
pif de plus pour justifier des règles
d'exception qui se pérénisent certaines
mesures de cette proposition de loi
répondent à ces deux remarques éclairé
par les travaux de la commission des
lois et du rapporteur
d'obress à ce titre on peut citer les
interrogations légitimes sur la sécurité
juridique à propos du nouvel article 1er
bis qui introduit donc la notion la
notion d'inconduite notoire comme motif
de retrait d'un surcil probatoire et
d'un suci socio
judiciaire cette notion si elle apparaît
déjà dans le code de procédure pénale
comme motif de révocation de la liberté
conditionnelle pâti d'un flou
important l'article 11 B devra également
être l'objet d'une attention
particulière à l'Ô de la protection
enfin et j'en terminerai par là le
renforcement de l'arsenal
judiciaire s'appliquant au mineurs
davantage encore plus pour les mineurs
donc moins de 16 ans doit appeler à la
plus grande
vigilance le moyen le plus
sûr mais le plus difficile de prévenir
les délis et de perfctionner l'éducation
disait
Bécar avant de judiciariser l'avenir des
mineurs il nous faut nous assurer que
tous les moyens éducatifs et sociaux ont
été mis en œuvre les réponses apporté à
la jeunesse conditionne le futur de la
nation notre responsabilité envers elle
est
immense ainsi le groupe RDSE se
maintiendra dans une dynamique
d'équilibre au service de la sécurité
des
citoyens merci la parole est à Madame
patri inger du groupe RDP pour 7
minutes monsieur le Président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui fait écho aux récents
attentats d'aras et du pont de birkheim
que nous avons que qui nous ont rappelé
avec violence à quel point la menace
terroriste reste prégnante dans notre
pays et que celle-ci n'est pas prête de
disparaître alors que nous évoquons ces
tristes événements avec le groupe RDPI
nous avons une pensée émue pour les
victimes et leurs familles qui ont tout
notre soutien nous pensons bien sûr
également aux forces de l'ordre et à nos
services de renseignement qui luttent
activement contre la menace terroristes
et tenons à rendre hommage à leurs
actions qu'il faut souligner depuis de
2017 a permis de déjouer pas moins de 43
attentats pour arriver à ce résultat
nous avons considérablement renforcé
notre arsenal depuis 2017 avec la loi
renforçant la sécurité intérieure et la
lutte contre le terrorisme avec la
création du parquet national
antiterroriste en 2019 ou encore la loi
du 24 août 2021 confortant le respect
des principes de la République loi dite
séparatiste avec la majorité
présidentielle et de manière
transpartisane nous avons en effet
considérablement renforcé les moyens
juridiques judiciaires et administratif
nécessaires à une lutte efficace contre
le terrorisme il s'agit d'une
préoccupation constante de la majorité
présidentielle toutefois comme cette
proposition de loi en fait le constat en
plus de rester élevé la menace
terroriste a considérablement évolué
depuis des attentats de 2015 tout
d'abord celle-ci peut désormais être le
fait de détenus ayant déjà pr purgé leur
peine ce qui pose la question de leur
prise en charge à l'issue de leur peine
les attaques terroristes sont ensuite
plus imprévisibles du fait de
l'évolution du profil des individus
radicalisés ces derniers ne bénéficient
plus nécessairement du soutien
logistique des groupes terroristes basés
à l'étranger comme daesh ou l'i mais
agissent davantage de façon solitaire il
peut s'agir d'assaillants plus jeunes
qui ont pu être endoctrinés via Internet
et des réseaux sociaux ainsi la
radicalisation des mineurs parfois très
jeunes peut s'opérer directement sur le
territoire national en dehors de tout
lieu de socialisation le texte de nos
collègues repose sur le constat que
l'arsenal pénal actuel ne permet pas
pleinement d'appréhander ses évolutions
il propose ainsi de remédier aux lacunes
Jud et administrative de notre système
avec le groupe RDPI nous ne pouvons que
souscrire à l'objectif poursuivi par les
auteurs de ce teex celui de garantir la
sécurité des Français en renforçant les
moyens de la lutte contre le terrorisme
et ce dans le contexte de tenue
imminente des Jos de Paris toutefois
nous sommes aussi convaincus que la
lutte contre le terrorisme ne peut pas
se faire que dans le respect de l'État
de droit et avions à ce titre des
réserves sur un certain nombre de
dispositions du texte initial et leur
conformité avec certains de des
principes fondamentaux inscrits dans
notre euh constitution aussi nous
tenions à saluer le travail du
rapporteur du sénateur rod dobress qui
s'est attaché à rechercher d'équilibre
entre opérationnalité des mesures
efficacité de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et garantir des droits et de
liberté constitutionnelle ainsi nous
saluons à titre d'exemple l'encadrement
fait par le rapporteur des mesures
judiciaires de sûreté en limitant
notamment le champ au seuls condamnés
pour des crimes à caractère terroriste à
des peines supérieur à 15 ans
d'emprisonnement ou 10 ans en cas de
récidive et d'autre part en prévoyant
une prise en charge adaptée au profil
radicalisé
la veillé à ce que le la mesure respecte
les critères de nécessité et de
proportionnalité en ce qui concerne les
mesures administratives de lutte contre
le terrorisme la substitution d'une
interdiction de paraître autonome à
l'interdiction initiale de paraître dans
les transports en commun dans le cadre
de la micas nous apparaît non seulement
moins attentoire aux libertés
individuelles mais s sous réserve des
observations qui pourront être faites en
séance ell nous semble même opportune
dans la perspective de la tenue des des
Jeux Olympiques et Parin olympique l'été
prochain si avec le groupe RDPI nous
sommes globalement favorable à ce texte
qui répond à une attente forte nous n'en
avons pas moins quelques réserves ainsi
l'ajout du critère d'unconduite notoire
comme motif de révocation d'un surcis
probatoire ou d'un suivi
socio-judiciaire ou encore l'ajoue du
critère de réétiration comme motif de
révocation d'une mesure de surveillance
judiciaire ou d'un suivi
sociaujudiciaire nous semble de nature à
nuire à la lisibilité du des dispositifs
concernés si nous devions si nous
devinons les intentions derrière ces
modifications
l'imprécision juridique de ces notions
nous fait craindre une forte une forme
d'arbit
d'arbitraire en conséquence avec le
groupe RDPI nous souscrivons pleinement
à l'objectif de ce texte qui part d'un
constat sinistre certes mais qui nous
semble pertinent et se propose d'adapter
l'arsenal dédié à la lutte
antiterroriste nous nous interrogeons
toutefois quant à la capacité de
certaines des mesures proposées à
concilier respect des principes
fondamentaux à notre État de droit et
lutte contre le
terrorisme aussi serons-nous
particulièrement attentifs aux arguments
les uns et des autres et plus
particulièrement à votre avis monsieur
le gardess saau je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Madame
Corine Narassiguin pour 7 9 minutes du
groupe socialiste écologiste
[Applaudissements]
républicain monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues depuis 20 ans les législations
sur le terrorisme se sont succédé au
point d'être aujourd'hui plus nombreus
que Cell sur l'immigration ce qui n'est
pas chose facile en 2009 Robert binter
alorsés président du Conseil
constitutionnel déclarait s'agissant du
terrorisme tout attentat aveugle dirigé
contre des civils anonymes par
définition innocent pour semer la
terreur et la dévastation est un crime
contre l'humanité la fermeté s'impose
cela dit la lutte contre le terrorisme
doit être conduite dans le respect des
principes de l'État de droit justement
parce que nous refusons l'idéologie de
mort et de violence des terroristes face
aux attentats terroristes qui nous ont
frappé et afin de prévenir et d'éviter
toute nouvelle attaque malgré le
formidable travail de nos services de
renseignement et de nos fonctionnaires
de police et de justice le débat sur la
modification et l'adaptation du droit
existant est légitime lorsque nous
étions aux responsabilités et que nous
avons vu les dangers augmentés au cours
des années 2010 en particulier entre
2012 et 2015 nous avons fait évoluer
notre doit en 2014 nous avons créé de
nouvelles infractions afin de permettre
la judiciarisation de personnes nétant
sont pas encore passé à l'acte violent
et de renforcer ainsi la capacité de
l'action judiciaire en 2015 la loi
relative au renseignement a donné à nos
services de renseignement la possibilité
de détecter dans un cadre légal les
risques qui pouvaient exister sur notre
territoire la loi du 3 juin 2016 dans le
domaine des infractions terroristes a
introduit la peine complémentaire de
suivi sociau-judiciaire qui instore
l'obligation de se soumettre sous le
contrôle du juge de l'application des
peines à des mesures de surveillance et
d'assistance destinées à prévenir la
récidive après l'exécution de la peine
nous sommes donc pour légiférer et
modifier le droit existant en cas de
nécessité mais à condition de toujours
s'assurer de l'équilibre indispensable
entre la sécurité de nos concitoyens et
le respect des libertés fondamentales et
individuelles si nous regardons bien les
motivations des terroristes qui s'en
prennent à notre pays il s'agit avant
tout de s'en prendre à ce que nous
sommes nos valeurs notre État de droit
notre justice aussi chaque fois que nous
modifions notre droit en fragilisant un
peu plus nos principes fondamentaux et
les droits de la défense nous reculons
face au terrorisme il y a quelques
années déjà la loi du 10 août 2020 dite
mesure de sûreté a fait l'objet d'une
large censure de la part du juge
constitutionnel dans sa décision du 7
août 2020 au motif que ces mesures
contrevenaient à la liberté d'aller et
de venir au droit au respect de la vie
privée au droit de mener une vie
familiale normale d'une manière qui
n'était ni adaptée ni proportionnée à
l'objectif de prévention d'actes
terroristes ensuite la loi du 30 juillet
2021 avait instauré une nouvelle mesure
judiciaire de prévention la récidif
terroriste et de réinsertion la mesure
judiciaire de sûreté cette fois-ci le
Conseil constitutionnel avait censuré
l'allongement des mesures individuelles
de contrôle administratif et de
surveillance
l'micas nous avons bien compris compris
que le projet de loi immigration a fait
céder de nombreuses digues dont celle de
la responsabilité du législateur
désormais des bans de la droite jusqu'à
l'Élysée jouer avec la Constitution et
nos droits fondamentaux est un nouveau
be opératoire
politique messieurs les ministres et
Monsieur le gardessau en particulier que
j'ai bien entendu vos mises en garde
bienvenu sur ce texte ne suffise pas il
faut faire obstacle pour notre part il
nous paraît toujours aussi inconcevable
que le Parlement fasse adopter des
dispositions qui seraient très largement
inconstitutionnelles et attentatoires
aux libertés individuelles nous
dénonçons ces bricolages législatifs
délibérés à des fins de communication
politique au sein de cette proposition
de loi de nombreux points sont
problématiques la création d'une
nouvelle mesure de sûreté la notion très
floue d'un conduite notoire qui
suffirait à renvoyer une personne en
prison et l'amendement proposé par le
rapporteur en séance ne nous semble pas
lever ce flou l' restauration de la
rétention de sûreté en cas de trouble
grave de la personnalité de
radicalisation persistante avec toujours
un risque d'arbitraire l'interdiction de
paraître lors des grands événements
l'interdiction de paraître dans les
transports publics qui peut être de 3
ans l'omniprésence constante du pouvoir
administratif par rapport au pouvoir
judiciaire aujourd'hui la rétention de
sûreté est une mesure exceptionnelle qui
ne concerne qu'un nombre restreint de
crimes graves dont le viol le meurtre ou
l'assassinat la torture et les de
barbarie l'enlèvement et la
séquestration elle a été créée par la
loi du 25 février 2008 pour les
individus particulièrement dangereux à
l'issue de l'exucation de leur peine en
voulant élargir les possibilités de
rétention de sûreté pour les crimes
terroristes vous souhaitez donc créer
une nouvelle peine après la peine non
pas pour un acte passé pour lequel aura
été prononcée une peine mais pour un Act
qui pourrait potentiellement avoir lieu
en raison de la dangerosité de la
personne selon des critères dont
l'imprécision laisse craindre une
application totalement arbitraire une
nouvelle peine non pas pour ce que la
personne a fait mais pour ce qu'elle est
et pour ce qu'elle peut peut faire vous
cherchez à instaurer une justice
prédictive nous refusons cette vision
digne de science-fiction
dystopique nous constatons une nouvelle
fois qu'aucune réflexion de fond n'est
menée notamment sur la radicalisation en
détention et les outils pour lutter
contre pire vous faites de la détention
la alpha et l'oméga de la peine sans
vous soucier d'une exposition à la
radicalisation renforcée en détention
pas à pas chers collègues vous êtes en
train de mettre à mal notre système
pénal et ainsi notre État de droit et
vous le savez Robert Badinter toujours
lui disait il y a 15 ans lors de la loi
2008 instaurant la sûreté notre système
de justice pénale repose sur le principe
de la responsabilité entendue comme
contrepartie de la liberté vous avez
choisi de violer la loi la peine qui
vous est appli et la sanction de cette
violation vous répondez de vos actes
selon les principes de l'État de droit à
partir du moment où l'on décide de
garder quelqu'un en détention au regard
d'un crime virtuel qu'il pourrait
commettre parce qu'on le considère comme
dangereux vous êtes passé dans un autre
système comment voulez-vous alors vous
défendre puisque vous n'êtes accusé de
rien comment les magistrats
diagnostiqueront-ils la dangerosité
potentielle avec ce texte vous souz
souhaitez nous faire passer d'une
justice de liberté à une justice de
sûreté renouant avec des courants de la
pensée du 19e siècle qui théorisait le
criminel né un individu atavique et
amoral commettant des crimes par
nécessité biologique tel un sauvage ce
texte c'est le renoncement à nos
principes fondamentaux de droit pénal la
présomption d'innocence le droit à la
réinsertion après la peine effectuée le
respect de la vie privée et familiale le
principe de non rétroactivité du droit
pénal le principe de non cumule des
peines c'est nier ce que toutes les
statistiques révèlent une véritable
réinsertion après la peine limite toute
récidive modifier ainsi notre droit
pénal serait un point de bascule mais
aussi et surtout un point de non retour
préparant une fois de plus tous les
outils à disposition d'un régime
autoritaire qui pourrait ainsi mettre
atteint notre démocratie enfin notons
deux articles dans cette proposition de
loi qui nous interpelle il s'agit des
articles 9 et 10 qui ne sont autes que
les articles 9 et 23 du projet de loi
immigration récemment adopté nous ne
comprenons pas bien ce qu'il vientent de
faire ici ou bien ils sont conformes à
la Constitution et il seront adoptés
définitivement après la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel du 25 janvier ou
bien ils seront censurés pour
inconstitutionnalité et donc vous
souhaitez nous faire voter deux articles
qui seraient contraires à notre
Constitution nous regrettons également
le véhicule législatif de la proposition
de loi qui par définition ne contient
pas d'avis du Conseil d'État au fond
nous partageons bien sûr l'objectif de
cette proposition de loi mais nous
considérons que les moyens doivent être
avant tout tournés vers le renseignement
la prévention et une application
proportionnée du droit existant vous
l'avez compris au cours de ce débat le
groupe socialiste conservera sa position
constante nous serons très vigilant
quant au respect de notre État de droit
de nos principes fondamentaux relatifs
au droit de la défense je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur André
Richard du groupe des Républicains pour
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président msieurs
les ministres monsieur le président de
la commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues pas de
sécurité sans
sûreté notre sécurité collective
nécessite en effet plus que jamais des
moyens de fermeté et des mesures de
sûreté à cet égard disons-le d'emblé la
présente PPL s'avère absolument
indispensable dès avant les attentats de
2015 à force de mission d'information et
de
nous avons produit collectivement au
Sénat une connaissance de nombreux
aspects du terrorisme nous mesurons par
conséquent et en particulier toute la
singularité du terrorisme son hybridité
comme on dit maintenant sa forme à la
fois civile et
armée à la fois politique et religieuse
qui nécessite des efforts constants de
nouvelles ressources et de moyens eux
mêmes hybride nous voudrions donc
insister sur l'importance d'une
perspective originale dressée par la
présente PPL un aspect qui n'est ni
préventif ni répressif
ou du moins qui n'est pas exclusivement
l'un nou l'autre il s'agit du suivi des
condamnés terroristes lequel est
indispensable indispensable d'une part
en raison de son adaptation à la menace
terroriste la coprésidence avec ma
collègue Nathalie Goulet d'un rapport
relatif à la radicalisation islamiste
dès 2015 et oui dès 2015 m'autorise à
rappeler une conclusion relevée à
l'époque et jamais démentie depuis il
n'est de terrorisme que
dissimulé menaçant queles qu'en soient
les apparences religieuses politiques ou
les formes insérées dans nos sociétés
modernes dans nombre de décisions qui
émanent du juge pénal et du juge de de
l'asile on relève toujours ces
stratégies de dissimulation les discours
manquants de cohérence ou de
vraissemblance les indices d'allégeance
et de loyautés occultes des condamnés
terroristes comment dès lors la liberté
ne risquerait-elle pas de cacher
elle-même
l'insécurité on ne peut lutter
efficacement contre qu'à l'aide de
mesures de suivi de peines
complémentaires et
personnalisées il faut se réjouir à cet
égard des dispositions de de ce texte
qui assure donc la sécurité de tous dans
nos transports dans nos manifestations
dans nos fêtes dans nos
célébrations la sécurité de tous par des
mesures de sûreté à l'égard de
quelques-uns si c'est
nécessaire indispensable ce texte est
encore en raison de son adéquation au
condamné terroristes en 2uxè lieu l'on
sait bien mes chers collègues à quel
point les discours de radicalisation
peuvent faire impression sur les esprits
simples ù je d'une part au moyen des
nouvelles technologies cela a été dit
d'autre part nous avons d'ailleurs
renforcé en 2022 la prévention de la
diffusion de contenu à caractère
terroriste en ligne et je me réjouis
d'ailleurs à cet égard en tant qu'ancien
rapporteur pour la commission des lois
qu'elle est enfin reçu son décret
d'application il reste toutefois à
rendre le plus sûr possible le suivi et
la déconnexion des mineurs condamnés de
ces differs canaux qui en réalité
peuvent favoriser leur isolement ça
c'est sûr et leur radicalisation de
temps en temps enfin et surtout cette
proposition de loi s'avère indispensable
pour son appréhension des condamnés
terroristes qui quel que soit leur
profil psychologique quel que soit leur
mobile présente une dangérosité
particulière cette notion de
dangérosité si imprécise soit-elle
contrairement à ce que l'on pour
pourrait attendre d'un dispositif
répressif ne peut-être ignoré et
abandonné par le droit comment ignorer
en effet que des actes de terrorisme
meurtrier peuvent être encore commis
après une radicalisation en prison un
fichagess et une multirécidive à hauteur
de 30 condamnations le sénateur d'Alsace
que je suis se souvient parfaitement
d'un tel profil mes chers collègues
puisque c'était celui du terroriste de
29 ans qui en son temps il y a 5 ans
avait frappé Strasbourg en plein marché
de Noël pour ne pas dire en plein cœur
dans ces circonstances comme tant dans
tant d'autres les mesures de sûreté
paraissent les mieux à mêm d'affronter
la dangérosité des condamnés si elles
persistent notre intervention mon
intervention ne serait pas complète si
elle n'évoquait pas un point important
qui semble pourtant passer entre les
mailles de ce texte monsieur le
Président messieurs monsieur le
rapporteur lorsque cette proposition de
loi affiche pour objectif de renforcer
le suivi des mineurs radicalisés c'est
son titre 2 il faut regretter qu'elle ne
s'intéresse pas plus résolument aux
acteurs en contact étroit avec les
jeunes dont notamment les enseignants et
les éducateurs sportifs qui seraient à
mon sens les plus à même de les suivre
pourtant dès 2014 déjà un rapport
sénatorial recommandait de mettre en
place je cite des actions obligatoires
de formation à la détection de la
radicalisation à destination des acteurs
de terrain et on les citait personnels
enseignants conseillers d'éducation
personnel de la PGJ et de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance éducateurs sportifs et
cetera malgré la création de référents
radicalisation au ministère de
l'Éducation par exemple cette offre de
formation pour les agents public reste
encore à réaliser et je prends
l'initiative d'attirer ici l'attention
sur l'offre de formation continue des
agents public titulaire et contractuel
qui pourrait efficacement être complété
et du surcroix à mon sens sans surcût
pour nos finances publiques
malheureusement les deux propositions
d'amendement que j'ai faites à cet égard
n'ont pas survécu au titre de l'article
40 ce que je ne comprends pas car le
financement de la formation continue de
ces agents ex existe bien il n'était pas
question de l'augmenter mais simplement
d'y affecter des priorités nouvelles
enfin pour conclure nous soutenons cette
proposition de loi également parce
qu'elle ajoute aux mesures de de
sécurité des moyens de fermeté ceci
semble indispensable car il concerne la
lutte contre le terrorisme là où elle
peut encore être renforcée la
dissolution des groupements l'expulsion
des étrangers et la sanction des
contenus numériques terroristes dans ces
domaines et face à une radicalisation
qui non seulement précède mais souvent
persiste après une condamnation pour
acte de terrorisme le présent texte
apporte une importante contribution elle
combine assurément la sécurité la sûreté
et la fermeté pour notre sécurité
commune je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Emeric Durox pour 3 minutes du groupe
des non
inscrit
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues depuis 2012
et les tuores abjectes de Mohamed Mera
notre pays a connu une cinquantaine
d'actes terroristes islamistes
provoquant 272 morts et 1200 blessés
selon les décomptes de la DGSI il
revient au législateur que nous sommes
de donner les armes juridiques
nécessaires au peuple français pour nous
prévenir collectivement d'un tel danger
ainsi cette proposition de loi qui
comporte trois nouvelles mesures de
sûreté applicables au condamnés pour
terrorisme afin de renforcer leur
surveillance à la sortie de détention
ainsi que d'autres dispositifs visant à
mieux contrôler et réprimer les auteurs
d'actes terroristes va dans le bon sens
c'est-à-dire dans le sens d'un
réarmement pour reprendre un mot à la
mode de la société face à cette
idéologie totalitaire et meurtrière ces
mesures reprennent d'ailleurs ce que
nous préconisons au rassemblé nationale
depuis des années à propos des
terroristes qui ne sont pas des
délinquants de droit commun il
poursuivent un but bien différent celui
de détruire la société il se fiche de la
réinsertion sociale bien au contraire il
la refuse totalement ils ne veulent pas
être réinsérés dans une société qu'ils
combattent et détestent mettre en place
des mesures de réintégration sociale les
concernants et voué à l'échec d'où
l'intérêt des mesures de sûreté qui
correspondent finalement au principe de
précaution inscrit dans la Constitution
néanmoins il conviendrait d'aller plus
loin dans la recherche de la protection
des Français nous proposons ainsi depuis
des années l'expulsion automatique des
terroristes étrangers aant commis leur
peine en France afin de dégager du temps
et de l'argent en terme de surveillance
et pour éviter tout risque de récidive
de la même façon il nous paraît opportun
de déchoir de la nationalité des
touristes français ayant commis des
actes contre notre pays ou l'ayyant
projeté et l'expulsion automatique de
tous ceux dotés d'une double nation vers
leur pays d'origine le Conseil d'État a
d'ailleurs en mai 2023 confirmé la
déchéance de nationalité décidée par le
gouvernement d'une francotturque de 25
ans condamné en 2017 pour avoir projeté
un attentat en France dans son
ordonnance le Conseil d'État a considéré
que la déchéance de nationalité de cet
individu n'était pas disproportionné au
regard de la nature et de la gravité des
faits commis depuis 19 2019 une
vingtaine de déchéances de nationalité
ont été prononcé pour terrorisme en
France mais il est impossible pour
l'instant de déchoir ceux qui sont nés
français il faut que la loi le permette
tous ceux qui ont porté les armes contre
notre pays sont indignes d'en posséder
la nationalité n'est français ou pas
enfin il convient de rappeler une
évidence le terrorisme islamique est un
phénomène importé par l'immigration
selon le fiaro en France seul sauf deux
exceptions c'est-à-dire deux Français
convertis tous les autres terroristes
islamistes depuis 2015 sont à plus ou
moins long terme le fruit de
l'immigration issu de pays musulmans
pour le si bien sûr que si s'il vous
plaît pour le chercheur chamb btiste me
le MI aujourd'hui reviendrait écouter
monsieur le ministre à renoncer à
expliquer une partie importante de ces
événements peut-être que l'explication
ne vous intéresse pas ainsi au-delà de
tout l'arsenal judiciaire la lutte
contre le terrorisme islamique passe
d'abord et avant tout par une maîtrise
totale de nos flux migratoire et leur
réduction drastique ce qui paraît la
chose la plus élémentaire pour tous les
Français je vous remercie de votre
attention malgré tout monsur merci la
parole est à Monsieur Louis
Vogel du groupe Les Indépendants
monsieur le Président monieur les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers
collègues la France est depuis toujours
l'une des cibles privilégiées des actes
terroristes très récemment encore
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard en
octobre
2023 nous a rappelé la prégnance de la
menace terroriste dans notre pays et la
tenue dans quelques mois ça a été
rappelé par le monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur la tenue en quelques mois
des Jeux Olympiques et paralympique
accroit les
risques les risques que fait peser la la
menace terroriste sont encore
renforcé par le fait comme l'a souligné
le rapporteur que les profils des
terroriste évolue d'exaction d'équipe
envoyé depuis
l'étranger la menace est aujourd'hui
devenue
endogène alimenté par des individus
installés sur le territoire et perméable
à l'idéologie
diihadiste bien que nos services de
renseignement a déjoué de nombreuses
actions terrorist ir et je salue
l'action de nos agents de sécurité il
faut aujourd'hui adapter notre droit
pour répondre à ces nouvelles formes de
terrorisme d'où cette proposition de loi
nous avions voté en
2021 une proposition de loi portant
diverses mesures de sûreté à l'encontre
des personnes condamné pour
terrorisme il faut compléter ce
dispositif
le texte que nous examinons procède à
plusieurs améliorations des dispositifs
existants et nous les soutenons il
s'agit tout d'abord d'élargir l'éventail
des mesures que le juge peut prononcer
il s'agit de mieux assurer le suivi des
exdtenus il s'agit d'étendre la
rétention de sûreté aux auteurs d'actes
terroristes
ensuite nos dispositions relatives au
contrôle judiciaire et à l'assignation
en résidence doivent être
modifié enfin nous sommes pleinement
favorables aux dispositions qui
permettent l'expulsion des étrangers
terroristes et leur interdiction du
territoire ces ces terroristes ne
méritent pas de rester sur notre
sol nous étions plus réservés je vous
l'avoue sur quant à la notion
d'inconduite notoire dont nous avons
parlé en commission des lois pouvant
justifier qu'il soit mis fin à une
semiliberté une détention à domicile
avec sous bracelet ou une libération
conditionnelle je salue la proposition
du rapporteur qui propose un amendement
permettant de remplacer cette
notion par une notion beaucoup plus
précise de comportement contraire aux
valeurs de la République ce qui est
directement dans le champ de
l'incrimination les obligations fixé
doivent être clair et précises pour le
que le le exécution soit sans équivoque
et que le juge puisse sanctionner des
manquements précis sans déborder ce ce
cadre la présente proposition nous
paraît contribuer utilement à renforcer
notre arsenal pénal tout en préservant
de façon équilibrée les libertés
fondamentales de nos concitoyens et en
respectant l'État de droit qui n'est pas
nécessairement un état faible le groupe
des indépendan soutiendra donc son
adoption merci chers collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Philippe bonnecè de
l'Union centriste pour 8
minutes monsieur
président monsieur le
Président messieurs les les ministres
monsieur le Président de la Commission
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
le terrorisme est toujours présent en
France cela a été largement rappelé et
la question posée cet après-midi et
avons-nous tout fait pour lutter contre
le terrorisme en l'absence de certitude
en tout cas à 100 % l'exécutif et le
Parlement ont l'obligation de faire le
maximum le gardessous a tout à l'heure
évoqué un objectif loable le président
de la commission des lois la volonté de
supprimer les angles morts je crois que
chacun est d'accord pour mener le plus
efficacement possible la lutte contre le
terrorisme je ne crois pas ma chère
collègue qu'il s'agisse d'une question
de communication politique je crois que
chacun ici se passerait bien d'avoir
amené ce combat euh ce sujet de la lutte
contre le terrorisme n'a jamais quitté
le champ des préoccupations du Parlement
depuis 2015 avec les mesures de l'état
d'urgence puis la loi ditsil de 2017 qui
a pris la suite puis la loi du 17 août
2020 qui a été rappelée avec la volonté
cré une mesure judiciaire de suivi et de
surveillance dite postendentielle et
vous avez bien sûr en tête nos
disposition 2021 qui
sanctuarisaiit les micas ces
interventions successive démontre la
difficulté de la tâche tant dans sa
dimension
opérationnelle que juridique et tout
votre travail a été là monsieur le
rapporteur
de tenter de de
concilier dans la l'analyse des
propositions de nos collègues auteurs de
la PPL ses contraintes opérationnelles
et la logique bien sûr de
conformité
constitutionnel ce volet constitutionnel
a été largement évoqué durant les débats
en dehors de toute référence à
l'actualité de demain bien entendu et il
peut-être vu à s sous deux angles euh
sur un plan direct est-ce que les
garanties qui sont proposées notamment
sur les mesures de sûreté je pense à
l'adhésion dite avérée à la probabilité
élevée et cetera permettent de franchir
le T le test de constitutionnalité on
voit bien que nous sommes sur des
éléments subtils mais il y a peut-être
aussi un deuxième élément qui est de se
poser la question si l'évolution de la
menace n'est pas aussi un élément qui
fait
évoluer l'appréciation de la
proportionnalité et de la nécessité des
mesures envisagé je serais tenté de dire
que les deux ont une influence tant
chacun constate l'évolution de la menace
terroriste vous avez fait référence mes
chers collègues au loup dit solitaire à
l'idée qu'il puisse y avoir une
radicalisation seule lorsque l'on
discute ce qui doit vous arriver bien
entendu dans vos départements avec les
responsables des mosquées ils font
référence à l'imam Google qui a remplacé
leur propre autorité donc il y a une
autor
radicalisation de la même manière que la
situation des personnes condamnées qui
sortent aujourd'hui de détention
changent avec des personnes qui ont été
condamnées à des peines plus longues en
matière de thorisme une réussite
objectivement c'est un des points
faibles de notre société limité dans la
lutte contre la déradicalisation et un
taux de trouble psychiatrique qui est
important dans ces conditions il est
normal d'examiner au mieux les
conditions à la fois d'équilibre et de
proportionnalité des mesures proposé je
ne crois pas qu'il y ait là dans cette
interrogation de référence à une notion
de de justice dite préductive quant à la
loi de sûreté 2008 on est assez loin des
sujets euh qui nous concerne aujourd'hui
de telle manière semble difficile de
reprendre des citations de l'époque
c'est dire que les deux nouvelles
rétentions de sûreté qui sont proposées
nous semblent aller groupe centristes
dans le bon sens en direction d'une part
des condamné pour fait de terrorisme
atteint de trouble psychiatriqu grave
l'autre des condamnés encore engagés
dans une idéologie dite radicale nous
approuvons cette extension nous
approuvons aussi que que soit
retravaillé c'est peut-être un des
points les plus délicats de la
proposition le déliit de recel
d'apologie du terrorisme la conciliation
entre les libertés le principe de
l'égalité d'une infraction et l'objectif
à valeur constitutionnelle publuique
raisonne effectivement
singulièrement il nous faut quand même
mesurer l'importance du sujet de fait à
traiter au-delà de la qualification
juridique si à l'occasion d'une visite
euh
domiciliaire et révéler la détention ou
l'enregistrement de données à caractère
terroriste que fait-on et on voit bien
que le choix est entre la
judiciarisation avec les garanties qui
en résultent et le rien le rien dans une
telle situation me paraît quand même
extrêmement perturbateur un risque qu'il
serait difficile de de prendre toute en
acceptant bien volontiers l'attention
que vous vous avez manifesté à la
qualité de rédaction de cette
disposition j'avoue aussi avoir un
faible pour la créativité des auteurs de
la PPL et de notre rapporteur avec
l'idée d'aller chercher si vous me
permettez cette formule la diffusion de
contenu faisant l'apologie du terrorisme
sur des réseaux certes privés de
communication lorsque l'ampleur de cette
diffusion ou l'absence de toute autre
communauté d'intérêt entre les
destinataires que l'intérêt pour pour le
terrorisme nous autorise je crois
effectivement que
l'autoradicalisation peut s'alimenter
tout particulièrement dans des groupes
de type WhatsApp Instagram et et autres
en tout cas dans la fréquentation d'un
environnement qui vous qui vous isole et
fournit une sorte de substrat mortifère
je suis peut-être un peu plus réservé
sur la notion de banissement numérique
en tant que peine complémentaire je
comprends que vous visez monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur les auteurs de la la
proposition de loi en particulier des
les mineurs mais je vois mal ce qui
interdirait de créer des des profils
successifs sauf que à ce que les
plateforme bannissent à partir de
l'identifiant de connexion ce qui me
paraît plus compliqué je vois mal aussi
la portée de l'interdiction de paraître
dans les transports en commun même si
vous avez en tête euh les Jeux
Olympiques quant aux observations sur
les articles 9 et 10 il est bien entendu
que tout ceci sera vu dans le cas de la
navette je termine regarde la lourdeur
ou de la noirceur du du sujet par un
côté un petit peu plus ludique à travers
la référence à
l'inconduite notoire comme motif de
retrait dans surs probatoire c'est vrai
que j'ai entendu cette référence elle
m'a un petit peu étonné et je partage
monsieur le rapporteur le souci qui a
été le vôre de trouver une référence le
Doig pendant admettre que l'article 733
du code de procédure pénale fait bien
référence à l'inconduite notoire comme
motif de retrait d'une libération
conditionnelle ce qui montre que le
droit pénal peut aussi comprendre
quelques
surprises merci chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Francis spiner du
groupe les républicains pour 6
[Applaudissements]
minutes
urés monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le garde des saau
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers
collègues le terrorisme c'est un venin
inoculé à la
démocratie et qui essae effectivement de
nous faire perdre nos valeurs pour
pouvoir dire ensuite que nous les
ressemblons dans un rapport de de non
droit et de violence on sait ce qu'il en
est advenu pour la démocratie américaine
à
Guantanamo le texte qui vous est soumis
aujourd'hui est un texte qui respecte
l'État de droit dont je rappelle que
l'État de droit n'est pas l'état de
faiblesse quelle a été la démarche du
président de la commission des lois et
du rapporteur c'est de faire le point
avec les acteurs de la lutte
antiterroriste pour voir au vu de
l'expérience d'un certain nombre de
dossier comment nous pouvions améliorer
l'efficacité des forces de l'ordre et de
l'institution
judiciare et donc ce qui vous est
proposé estil de nature à être contraire
à l'état de droit alors j'en viens à la
disposition la plus
contestée c'est celle de la
rétention et là vous êtes
extraordinaire la rétention nous ne
l'avons pas inventé et ce n'est pas
monsieur le garde des saau de la justice
prédictive la rétention elle existe dans
le code de procédure pénale
elle existe dans le code de procédure
pénale voté
avalisé et ce que nous faisons c'est de
rajouter à côté des violeurs des
pédophiles des assassins et des auteurs
des actes de barbarie les terroristes ça
vous choque ça vous choque d'ajouter à
cette liste ceux qui sèent la terreur et
qui tue car c'est de cela qu'il s'agit
et donc en réalité si vous relisez
l'article 706- 53 et 13 du code de
procédure pénale vous verrez qu'il
s'agit d'une mesure exceptionnelle et
qui obéit à certain nombre de conditions
c'est dire que vous ne pouvez pas dire à
nos concitoyens que nous allons refuser
une mesure exceptionnelle encadré par la
loi et qui existe déjà et qu'en faisant
cela nous portons atteinte aux libertés
après vous vous inquiétez vous vous
inquiétez vous vous inquiétez de des
problèmes de dissolution des
association le terrorisme c'est une
chaîne entre celui qui tue mais il y a
celui qui lou l'appartement il y a celui
qui fournit les armes il y a celui qui
fournit la voiture il y a toute une
série et il y a des
associations qui sont des Agen de voyage
qui vont en Turquie en Surie à da et
bien il faut avoir tous les moyens de
lutter mais c'est dis
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur le
sait ce fond sous le contrôle de la
justice administrative qui ne partage
pas toujours les analyses que nous
faisons c'est ça l'État de droit c'est
la vision que nous avons de lutter
contre le terrorisme sous le contrôle du
juge donc je ne vois pas en quoi ces
dispositions portent atteinte encore une
fois à l'état de droit alors si je
prends le
reste les mineurs radicalisés est-ce que
vous pensez que lorsqu'on met un Mineur
de plus de 13 ans prison c'est parce que
vraiment on considère que c'est péchés
véniel j'étais il y a 3 semaines devant
le tribunal criminel pour enfant contre
les gamins qui avaient
dénoncé vendu Samuel paatti à leur
assassin 30 mois de pris 20 mois de
prison dont une partie avec sourcil
alors vous pensez bien que quand on met
en prison on le fait pour des raisons
impérieuse et nécessaire et puis j'en
viens au délit de Rossel d'apologie du
terrorisme
le pèreamel a été
tué parce qu'en 48 he sur WhatsApp les
assassins se sont rencontrés et cette
boucle WhatsApp elle été suivie par le
renseignement territorial
elle n'ont pas eu les moyens d'arrêter
et si ces textes avaient existé on
aurait pu intervenir alors il faut moi
je veux bien que dans un monde parfait
on peut effectivement tout faire on peut
sonder les cœurs les rein et se dire
qu'on va sauver tout le monde mais
l'efficacité commande de nous donner les
moyens de lutter contre le terrorisme et
même si il y a dans cette proposition de
loi un paquet de mesures qui semble
séparé en réalité c'est l'expérience du
terrain qui nous amène à donner tous ces
éléments et puis j'ai un point de
divergence avec le rapporteur il le sait
il a fait un très gros travail mais
effectivement l'inconduite notoire
monsieur boncer a raison elle existe
dans le code de procédure pénale
effectivement et lorsque un avocat a
contesté cette mesure il a demandé à
saisir le Conseil constitutionnel compte
tenu du fait qu'il estimait cette notion
trop vague et la Cour de cassation la
chambre criminelle qui porte parfois
bien son nom la chambre criminelle a
estimé qu'il n'y avait pas lieu de
transmettre la QPC ce qui fait que le
Conseil constitutionnel n'a pas eu à se
prononcer encore sur la notion de
l'inconduite notoire mais je pense que
ça n'est pas possible et la nouvelle
formulation qui a été faite
personnellement ne me satisfait pas mais
pour l'ensemble c'est un texte efficace
utile qui ne viole aucun principe
juridique que nous vous demandons
d'adopter j'ajouterai enfin monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur a dit il avait
raison qu'il y a un aspect du texte qui
le
chagrinait c'était lorsque les imam
faisait l'apologie du
terrorisme et il s'inquiétait que le que
dans les lieux de culte et il
s'inquiétait que le Conseil d'État a
émis un avis défavorable j'ai beaucoup
de respect pour le Conseil d'État mais
le Conseil d'État comme son nom
l'indique ne donne que des conseils en
la matière il ne dit pas la conformité à
la Constitution et comme vous l'avez
fait remarquer il est quand même
extraordinaire que le ministre du culte
soit protégé quand il est agressé que
ces lieux soi protégés comme circonstan
aggravante quand il est victime il a le
droit à toute la considération du
Conseil d'État et quand il serait auteur
il aurait le droit à toute son
indulgence voilà pourquoi je pense qu'il
faut le maintenir je vous remercie merci
merci chers collègue
merci la discussion générale est close
nous passons à la discussion du texte de
la commission l'article 1er je suis
saisi d'un amendement numéro 31 la
parole est à Madame Nara
CIN merci monsieur le Président nous ne
avec cet amendement nous ne souhaitons
pas discuter ici le principe même des
mesures de de sûreté qui a déjà été
débattu à mainre reprise nous souhaitons
encore moins remettre en cause tout ce
qui peut aller dans le sens d'un
renforcement de l'accompagnement médical
et psychiatrique nous tenons cependant à
marquer notre opposition à certaines des
évolutions introduites par le rapporteur
en effet l'application d'une mesure de
sûreté décidée à partir d'un risque de
récidive et l'adhésion à une idéologie
incitant au terrorisme est extrêmement
délicate d'autant plus que cette mesure
pourrait désormais trouver à s'appliquer
en cas de Ré itération d'une infraction
à caractère terroriste un champ bien
plus large que celui défini par la
version initiale de la proposition de
loi qui viser la récidive or les
infractions à caractère terroriste
peuvent couvrir une multitude d'actes à
la dangerosité et à la gravité variable
donc les les transformations
législatives proposées semblent à la
fois superflu et dangereuses et je vous
pose la question monsieur l'auteur de la
profession lo et monsieur le rapporteur
je vous pose la question en quoi une
adhésion avérée est est-elle plus facile
ou plus pertinente à caractériser qu'une
d'adhésion
persistante du propre aveu du rapporteur
en réunion de commission la rédaction
actuelle qui encadre cette mesure de
sûreté serait trop peu opérationnelle
mais ce constat n'est-il pas rassurant
il démandre simplement que des mesures
aussi exceptionnel doit être strictement
encadré et ne peuvent s'appliquer qu'à
une fraction infinite esésimale de la
population à moins que vous ne
considériez que des millions de
terroristes sont en liberté dans les
rues et donc je le rappelle notre
objectif c'est c'est vraiment
l'efficacité et l'opérationnalité de la
loi merci quel est l'avis de la
commission alors l'avis de la commission
est des favorable vous venez de le dire
à juste titre on cherche l'efficacité et
notre collègue spissner vient de
remarquablement dire les choses aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on
constate le parquet antiterroriste nous
dit c'est une bonne mesure de prévention
de la récidive terroriste mais nous
n'arrivons pas à la la caractériser la
dangerosité cont tenu de la manière dont
c'est rédigé dans la loi actuellement et
donc je pose tout simplement la question
au
procureur général antiterroriste en lui
demandant qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
trouver comme meilleure formulation et
il me dit plutôt plutôt une probabilité
élevée de récidif que très élevée et
plutôt une adhésion avérée que une
adhésion persistante aux idéologies donc
moi je ne vais pas réinventer des choses
et je pense qu'on aura plus ité qu'on
pourra condamner plus facilement avec
cette formulation donc avis
défavorable avis du
gouvernement le Gouvernement émet un
avis favorable à cet amendement je vais
vous dire pourquoi en l'état du droit la
mesure judiciaire de prévention de la
récidive terroriste qui a été créée par
la loi de juillet
2021 peut-être prononcé à l'égard de
personnes qui présentent à l'issue de
leur peine une dangerosité caractérisée
par une probabilité très élevée de
récidive et par une adhésion persistante
à une idéologie ou à des thès incitante
à la commission d'acte de terrorisme ces
critères reprennent ceux qui sont
applicables au micas c'est la raison
pour laquelle je suis d'accord avec
l'auteur de l'amendement il convient de
ne pas multiplier les rédactions
permettant d'appréhender la
radicalisation merci je vais mettre au
voix cet amendement avec un avis
favorable de la commission défavorable
du
gouvernement
défavorable de la commission favorable
du gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote
contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté je suis saisi de l'amendement
numéro 47
monsieur
dobres président
RAC c'est
rédactionnel du gouvernement
sagesse je mets au voix cet amendement
avec un avis favorable de la commission
sagesse du gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote contre l'amendement est
adopté je mets au voix l'article 1er qui
vote pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
article 1er est adopté je suis saisi de
trois amendements identiques numéro 12
monsieur
bénaroche monsieur le Président je
dirais que les discussions en commission
et le bon sens d'ailleurs ont amené le
rapporteur à à levé à relevé cette
notion de la conduite lotoire dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure cela dit c'est
remplacé par la la notion lorsque son
comportement manifeste qu'il ne respecte
pas les principes de la public en plus
d'être flou et donc sujet un arbitraire
sa constatation suffirait à révoquer
donc de ce fait un surcis probatoire or
le surcis probatoire se base sur des
obligations prononcées par le juge t que
l'obligation de travailler de suivi de
formation l'obligation de soi
l'interdiction de ser dans certains
lieux et cetera le non suivi de ces
obligations est un critère beaucoup plus
objectif je rappelle aussi que le
contrôle des obligations est effectué
par le juge d'application des peines qui
est appuyé par les conseillers
pénitentiaires d'insertion et de
probation les C PIP et que ces
conseillers pénitentiaires sont toujours
en attente d'une profonde revalorisation
de leur carrière je profite de cette loi
pour rappeler ce besoin de réarmer ces
services
essentiels merci Monsieur
brossa merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre cet article ajouté
en commission la semaine dernière
complète comme vient de le dire
guberaroche dans le code de procédure
pénale les motifs de retrait d'un d'un
surcis probatoire et et d'un suivi
sociaujudiciaire par la notion
d'unconduite notoire tout d'abord sur la
forme il fait partie des articles de
cette proposition de loi qui dépasse le
seul cadre de la législation
antiterroriste qui ne peut pas nous
convenir sur le fond si nous pouvons
souscrire à l'objectif de lutte
antiterroriste cela suppose de légiférer
avec le plus de précautions poss
possible en témoigne les multiples
censures du Conseil constitutionnel bien
que déjà présente dans le code de
procédure pénale la notion d'inconduite
notoire est selon nous source
d'insécurité juridique et est contraire
à la lisibilité notre droit c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous déposons cet
amendement de suppression merci Madame
narigin madame de la
ganterie merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues messieurs les les
ministre bon on a eu ce débat en
commission des
lois la notion d'inconduite notoire
alors moi j'entends c'est pas la
première fois collègue rapporteur
d'obess on fait référence au procureur
national antiror ça formidable enfin que
je sache n'est pas lui qui rédige la loi
et je pense qu'il faut qu'on évite quand
même d'écrire nos article sous la dicté
d'un d'un procureur toujours est-il que
un conduite notoire ça ne veut rien dire
d'ailleurs en commission vous n'avez pas
su éclairer ce que concrètement cela
voudrait dire
alors les objections sont lesquelles le
critère de lisibilité de la loi qui est
un motif de censure constitutionnelle
donc si cette loi était déférée devant
le conseil l'incondu notoire sera
censurée donc je sais bien que et la
majorité du Sénat et le et le
gouvernement c'estz peu farouche sur cet
aspect d'inconstitutionnalité mais il
faut se reprendre donc il y a ça et puis
un autre argument mais peut-être notre
collègue spiner l'évoquera donc je ne
veux pas lui enlever son argument de ce
fait la proposition sur laquelle nous
viendrons plus tard du rapporteur
deobesse n'est pas plus
efficace encore une fois il s'agit de
d'une sanction qui est radicale et donc
il faut que les critères soient précis
on est en matière pénale et donc on ne
peut pas rester dans le flou simplement
parce que un procureur antiterroriste
aurait dit ah ben oui mais c'est
embêtant parce qu'il y a des gars on
sait pas mais cependant on a
l'impression mais ça va pas et cetera
c'est pas ça notre
travail quelle est la vie de la
commission monsieur le Président si vous
permettez je vais présenter mon
amendement aussi parce que c'est c'est
le même débat enfin sous votre avec
votre
accord effectivement j'exliqu en
commission je le redis pour les
collègues qui qui n'y participeit pas
que d'abord madame de La Gonterie moi je
fais pas des amendements sous la dicté
tel ou tel si vous avez lu mon rapport
et je ne doute pas que vous l'ayez fait
vous aurez vous auriez vu que j'ai tenu
compte d'observation des des juges
d'application des peines du procureur
antiterroriste des des tribunaux pour
enfants et sur les questions des mineurs
et de tas de de professionnel du droit
je veux dire je c'est pas tel ou tel la
question c'est nous sommes confrontés à
de nouvelles formes de terrorisme
endogène comment pouvons-nous être plus
opérationnel plus efficace dans le
respect des libertés bon donc
euh on nous dit et c'est vrai que
facialement un certain nombre de
condamnés respectent quand ils sont euh
euh en prison à certain nbre de choses
mais qu'on peut démontrer qu'ils ont des
comportements à l'extérieur notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux qui ne sont pas
forcément des comportements exemplaires
c'est moins qu'on puisse dire et donc on
m'a parlé d'un conduite notoire j'ai
vérifié d'ailleurs monsieur bonnecère
l'a dit ça existe déjà dans le code de
procédure pénale mais c'est vrai que
c'est la définition est est est un peu
euh sibiline donc j'ai repris le débat
en commission aujourd'hui même
d'ailleurs et j'ai dit que le terme d'
conduite notoire était une mauvaise
formulation donc je je je le retire
parce que de fait on a des risques
juridiques certains on a repris par
contre les mots lorsque le comportement
manifeste qu'il ne respecte pas les
principes de la République puisque mes
chers collègues nous l'avons voté il y a
pas très longtemps dans la loi
immigration au Sénat donc ça a été voté
on verra bien d'ailleurs ce que le
Conseil constitutionnel nous dit dans
quelques jours mais non mais au moins
nous nous partons sur une notion qu'on
peut caractériser mais avoir des
comportements manifestement
irrespectueux par rapport au principe de
la République ça peut se caractériser
donc défavorable au deux autres
amendements et favorable à celui-là même
si je l'ai dit à d'autres collègues je
suis évidemment ouvert si nous avons un
suivi rapide à l'Assemblée nationale
dans la navette à une nouvelle
formulation avis du
gouvernement monsieur le Président là on
évoque les amendements 12 28 et 32 c'est
ça d'accord c'est sagesse d's je veux
rassurer madame de La Gonterie c'est pas
le procureur national antiterroriste qui
dicte quoi que ce soit non non il
applique la loi il applique la loi comme
tous les magistrats de ce pays ils sont
dit-on selon la formule consacrée la
bouche de la loi mais je pense en
revanche que il n'est pas inutile du
tout que l'on prenne àachche avec le
procureur national antiterroriste qui
répond aux questions qui lui sont posées
et je pense que son
expérience euh est extrêmement utile
pour éclairer nos débats voilà ce que je
me permets de dire rassurez-vous chacun
est à sa place et le procureur national
antiterroriste n'a pas violé la sacro
sainte règle de la séparation des
pouvoirs je défends le procureur
national antiterroriste oui totalement
et j'entends bien que on puisse
l'auditionner et qu'on puisse s'inspirer
des réponses qui sont les siennes je ne
vois pas là que le
pnat pour reprendre l'acronyme soit
celui qui dicte la loi au
législateur merci je mets au voix ces
trois amendements avec deux avis
défavorables qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient ils
sont pas adoptés monsieur
le c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça il s'est
exprimé monsieur le rapporteur l'avis du
Gouvernement sur sagesse aussi
évidemmentad madame narassiga
oui pour une explication de vote sur
l'amendement du rapporteur
d'bress remplacer un conduite notoire
par lorsque le comportement du condamné
manifeste qu'il ne respecte pas les
principes de la République nous avions
déjà signalé lors du débat sur le projet
de loi immigration que ça ça portait des
des risques d'inconstitutionnalité étant
donné toujours le flou et donc la menace
d'arbitraire et il s'agissait à l'époque
uniquement de euh j'allais dire
uniquement de titre de séjour ce qui
déjà en soi est un sujet très sérieux
euh là il s'agit d'envoyer des gens de
renvoyer des gens en prison euh et donc
ça n'est pas plus acceptable que la
notion d'inconduite notoire donc c'est
pour cela que nous voterons contre cet
amendement voilà merci je vais mettre au
voix l'amendement un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement sur l'amendement de la
commission qui va
ouais donc je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
c'est adopté je mets au voix l'article 1
B qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'article 1 bis est
adopté et
votter l'amendement numéro
46 c'est
Madame
rigin
oui merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à supprimer l'ajout par
le rapporteur d'un nouveau motif de
révocation d'une surveillance judiciaire
ou d'un suivi socio-judiciaire à savoir
la commission d'une nouvelle infraction
premièrement nous aimerions rappeler que
cette proposition de loi est censé être
motivé par la lutte antiterroriste et
être ciblé sur les condamnés terroristes
or cet article prier TER aura des effets
bien plus large d'autre part pourquoi
toute nouvelle condamnation devrait-elle
entraîner la révocation d'un suivi
sociaujudiciaire devrait-on révoquer ce
type de mesure à l'aveugle de manière
automatique sans aucune prise en compte
du contexte de la personnalité ou tout
bêtement d'un du type d'infraction
auquelle se rapporte cette nouvelle
condamnation est-ce que ça va
s'appliquer aux infractions routières
par exemple d'autant plus que l'article
723 35 du code de procédure pénale
dispose d'ors et déjà que la juridiction
de jugement qui décide de cette nouvelle
condamnation peut révoquer la
surveillance judiciaire pour tout crime
ou délit pour lequel le suivi sociau
judiciaire est encouru après avis du
juge d'application des peenes ce qui est
déjà tout à fait équilibré et
fonctionnel cette cet article nous
paraît donc tout à fait dangereux et
superflu merci quel est l'avis de la
commission Mons le rapporteur c'est un
amendement de suppression donc
défavorable avis du gouvernement même
position
défavorable je mets au voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui vote
pour qui vote
contre il n'est pas adopté je mets au
voix l'article 1er TER qui vote pour qui
vote contre qui
s'abstient prier ter est adopté article
2 je suis saisi de l'amendement numéro
33 madame
Narin dans dans l'état actuel du droit à
titre exceptionnel on continue
d'enfirmer une personne malgré la fin de
sa peine lorsqu'elle présente une
dangerosité carct par une probabilité
très élevée de récidive parce qu'ell
sou'ouvrent d'un trou trouble grave de
la personnalité nous avons deux choses
ici une conjonction de subordination qui
marque une relation causale et le
trouble de la Grave de la personnalité
qui renvoie à une pratique psychiatrique
longue connue et une évaluation d'ordre
médical ce qui est proposé dans cette
proposition de loi nous en demandons la
suppression c'est d'ajouter une nouvelle
possibilité d'enfermer quelqu'un sans
qu'il ait été condamné pour cela s'il
présente une particul parculière
dangerosité caractérisée par une
probabilité très élevée de récidive et
par une adhésion persistante à une
idéologie ou à des thèses incitant à la
commission d'actes de terrorisme
monsieur le rapporteur dans votre
rapport consacré au bilan de la loi silt
en 2020 ce que vous écriviez à propos du
suivi judicière peut être répété
maintenant les conditions d'appréciation
de la dangerosité et du risque de
récidive reposent exclusivement sur un
examen clinique confié à des experts
psychiatres or comme l'ont indiqué des
représentants du parquet national
antiterroriste à la mission une telle
procédure initialement conçue pour des
auteurs d'infraction à caractère sexuel
ne permet que difficilement d'apprécier
la dangerosité d'un point vue
criminologique des condamnés terroristes
qui ne présentent pas dans leur grande
majorité de troubles mentaux dans la
pratique les experts sollicités peinent
à se prononcer sur les cas de condamné
pour des faits de terrorisme rendant
parfois complexe pour le magistrat le
prononcer d'une telle mesure y compris
dans les cas où la dangerosité paraît
évidente monsieur le rapporteur de
quelle évidence
parliez-vous vous semblez donc avoir la
préciance dont euh manquent tous les
praticiens nous avons bien réfléchi
avez-vous bien réfléchi aux conséquences
de ce qui est dans ce texte merci l'avis
de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez raison de relire ce
que je disais à l'époque euh chers
collègues bon là vous ne supprimez pas
tout l'article donc euh vous êtes
d'accord sur un principe mais avec les
deux alinéas que vous supprimer euh
finalement vous reprenez quasiment les
critères existants pour une mesure de
prévention de la récidive très
restrictive qui serait constitutif d'une
infraction d'association de malfaiteur
terroriste si je reprends votre texte
c'est-à-dire vous allez très loin moi je
j'essaie de trouver euh des critères qui
correspondent quand on sort de plus de
15 années de détention à la suite d'un
crime terroriste euh qui a une
probabilité de récidive très élevé que
l'on puisse prendre en charge de façon
permanente dans une structure
spécialisée au fin
radicalisation un certain nombre de
personnes et que cette mesure obéisse à
une procédure pluridisciplinaire qui
inclut des expertise médicale et qui ne
peut être appliqué que pour les seuls
criminels terroristes condamnés à des
peines supérieurs à 15 ans
d'emprisonnement et à condition qu'il
n'existe aucune autre mesure moins
stricte donc je considère que nous
garantissons avec toutes ces garanties
la proportionnalité je suis donc
défavorable avis du
gouvernement
c'est pour le gouvernement un avis de
sagesse et je vais vous dire pourquoi
répondante en cela à la philiipique que
j'ai dû subir de la part de Francis
spiner Francis spiner il a dit mais de
sa voix si belle et si grave mais enfin
vous acceptte ça depuis 2008 notamment
pour les viols et vous ne l'accepteriez
pas ah il est là vous Neac
pas pour le terrorisme mais c'est pas ça
le problème monsieur le sénateur pas du
tout vous avez pas bien regardé les
choses ce qui m'étonne je sais que vous
êtes toujours minutieux et scrupuleux
dans l'analyse que vous faites des
textes en réalité il manque un petit
quelque chose là aujourd'hui c'est les
troubles mentaux duent constaté et donc
qu'est-ce que vous avez comme
possibilité pour votre rétention de
sûreté une dangerosité criminologique et
rien d'autre
alors quand vous me dites le viol et les
autres infractions qui ont permis en
2008 oui dans T non mais plutôt que le
portable regardez le texte aujourd'hui
on supprime le trouble mental qui peut
nous inquiéter tous et qui fait que la
rétention de sûreté peut-être prononcée
voilà la différence et pardonnez-moi
elle n'est pas elle n'est pas neutre
elle est de taille cette différence donc
j'ai mis un avis de sagesse moi j'ai dit
que je pensais que c'était une
discussion que c'était contestable sur
le plan constitutionnel mais le Sénat
dira ce qu'il a à dire dans la grande
sagesse dont il est coutumier madame de
La
Gandie merci monsieur le
Président je pense qu'il faut euh
poursuivre le raisonnement du garde des
sauts gouvernement donne un avis
défavorable de manière extrêmement
argumenté nous sommes ici au cœur de la
justice prédictive le problème que nous
avons dans les infractions terroriste
c'est que nous sommes incapables en
réalité d'identifier des troubles
mentaux de la part de celles et ceux
plutôt ceux d'ailleurs qui les
commettent donc on a déjà comment dire
prévu chacun en a pensé ce qu'il voulait
une entorse au à ce principe euh d'une
d'une sanction postsententielle c'est le
cas de le dire mais au moins on était
dans le cadre des des troubles mentaux
et monsieur le rapporteur d'bress le
pnat dit la même chose il dit au fond
bah on ne sait pas faire on ne sait pas
encadrer par la constatation de troubles
mentaux cette situation donc si vous
votez ce dispositif vous mettez le doigt
dans la justice prédictive et vous ne
vous arrêterez jamais et donc vous
considérez que toute personne condamnée
recommettra une infraction plus tard et
c'est en cela que le problème est grave
et c'est en cela que c'est
inconstitutionnel
merci je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement avec un avis défavorable de
la commission un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote
contre il n'est pas adopté je mets au
voix l'article 2 qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté après l'article 2 un
amendement numéro 1 présenté par Madame
Nathalie Goulet oui monsieur le
Président monieur les ministres mes
chers collègues il s'agit d'un d'un
amendement qui vient d'une d'une
proposition de loi à la suite d'un
différents incidents notamment en 19 en
2021 le le meurtre du père Olivier ma en
en
vendet cette cet assassinat a été
l'occasion de mettre en exerg ce qui me
semble être une incohérence de notre
législation puisqu'il est possible à la
justice de prononcer des mesures qui
nécessiteront la présence de la personne
sur le territoire national alors même
que légalement elle n'a pas le droit d'y
être et devrait le quitter immédiatement
euh il est donc proposé de prévoir que
les personnes dépourvues ditre de séjour
ou faisant l'objet d'une mesure
d'éloignement ne puissent pas être
condamnés à des peines qui nécessitent
pour leur exécution une présence
effective sur le territoire national il
semblerait qu'il est là une une
incohérence puisque le fait d'avoir une
mesure par exemple d'intérêt général va
va euh empêcher l'exécution d'une qtf ça
me semble une incohérence alors c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai déposé le
présent amendement avis de la commission
Mons le
rapporteur alors madame Goulet soulève
un vrai problème qui a ému toute la
France à l'époque effectivement c'est la
conciliation entre déroulement d'une
procédure judiciaire d'une personne mise
en examen et procédure d'éloignement on
avait je le rappelle ici à nos collègues
ce débat lors de la loi séparatiste et à
l'époque nous n'avions pas souhaité
faire primer l'éloignement sur la
procédure judiciaire parce que si on le
fait ça devient virtuellement impossible
pour les victimes d'obtenir réparation
et donc je pense que les arguments sont
toujours valables aujourd'hui je demande
quand même l'avis du gouvernement pour
qu'il nous le confirme ou pas mais s'il
nous le confirme j'aurai un avis
défavorable avis du
gouvernement pas éloigner les gens avant
qu'ils aent été jugés ça me paraît une
évidence et comment font les particip
civil mais donc cet argument qui était
un des arguments de la discussion
euh dans un cadre très très particulier
je je je vais pas le rappeler ici cette
affaire n'est pas terminé d'ailleurs
donc il m'est interdit de M de m'y
pencher davantage mais en revanche le
débat public suscité par cette question
fallait-il comment dirais-je éloigner ou
fallait-il maintenir l'intéressé à
disposition de la justice me paraît
avoir été tranché dans un sens qui est
évidment favorable aux victimes et
qu'aurait-on dit si ce monsieur avait
été éloigné et qu'aurait dit les partis
civiles et bon donc en en l'état moi je
suis défavorable à
l'amendement je vais je vais mettre au
voix cet amendement madame Goulet
allez-y oui oui effectivement j'ai eu
une une phase d'Er je vais retirer
l'amendement
he il est retiré après l'article 2 un
amendement numéro 13 monsieur bénaroche
oui monsieur le Président cet amendement
d'appel est là pour amener dans la
discussion le sujet de l'organisation
territoriale judiciaire de la lutte
antiterroriste parce que le pouvoir
judiciaire nous paraît le parempauvre de
la lutte antiterroriste dominé en la
matière à la fois par les services de
renseignement et
l'administration via les préfets notre
groupe demande la mise en place de pôles
judiciaaires interrégionaux
antiterroristes à l'image des
juridictions interrégionales spécialisé
actuellement compétente en matière de
lutte contre la criminalité organisée
qui ont fait leur preuve dans le
démantellement des réseaux la mission
d'enquête actuelle du Sénat est en train
de le confirmer la création de
structures spécialisées dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme au sein du tribunal
de Grande espense de Paris doit être
étendu au niveau régional afin de
contribuer au renforcement du
rassaignement territorial sur l'ensemble
du territoire français pour une
meilleure prévention des projets
criminels l'avis du l'avis de la
commission rapporteur c'est une demande
de rapport donc défavorable avis du
gouvernement euh même avis sauf si c'est
au ministre de l'intérieur des autres
maires que vous le demandez le
rapport je mets au voix cet amendement
avec deux avis défavorables qui vote
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas adopté
à l'article 3 je suis saisi de deux
amendements identiques monsieur benaroch
pour le
14agit d'un article de suppression d'un
amendement de suppression de l'article 3
qui a pour objet de déroger au droit
pénal spécial des mineurs pour étendre
la durée maximale du placement en centre
éducatif fermé ou en détention
provisoire des mineurs radicalisé ou en
voie de radicalisation et placé sous
main de justice cet article va l' code
du principe de l'autonomie du droit
pénal des mineurs délinquant qui
consiste à adapter la réponse pénale en
tenant ce de la minorité de l'auteur de
l'infraction cette spécificité qui
autorise l'aménagement des règles
procédurales est sans cesse remise en
cause par les républicains au Sénat
d'année en année la procédure pénale des
mineurs se rapproche de celle des
majeurs pourtant les mineurs radicalisés
et délinquant sont aussi victimes d'un
environnement et en perte de repère ils
sont par essence influençables et
doivent être protégés contre les attêtes
à leur libre arbitre la pauvreté et
l'isolement social des mineurs sont par
exemple des facteurs propice à leur
radicalisation qui peutv même
s'apparenter à un phénomène d'emprise
sectaire à ce titre le législateur a
déjà prévu une incrimination
d'incitation des mineurs à participer à
un groupement terroriste cette in
crimination inscrite à article
421-2-4-1 du code pénal sanctionne tout
etroit faisant la promotion des
mouvements sectaires ou radicaux auprès
des mineurs aussi le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire réaffirme
l'intérêt de justice péndale des bideur
qui tienent compte des spécificités
d'atténuation de la responsabilité
pénale en fonction de l'âge de la
primauté de l'éducatif sur les répressif
de la spécialisation des juridictions et
des procédures à l'égard des mineurs le
tout répressif et les mesures
coercitifes ont un impact fort et
néfaste sur leur avenir et sur leur
construction une politique de prévention
contre la radicalisation à la hauteur
des enjeux serait bien plus efficass
pour lutter contre l'embrigadement que
la simple surencherre répressive
merci le
34 madame merci monsieur le Président
donc c'est un amendement dans le dans la
même veine en demandant la suppression
de cet article qui nous semble en fait
contraire à l'esprit qui doit gouverner
la justice des
mineurs et je voudrais rappeler quand
même la note du ministère de de la
justice du 10 février
2017 sur le traitement de cette question
là avec les mineurs je viens de passer
48 heur d'immersion dans les services de
du SPIP de Gironde et j'ai pu mesurer le
travail vraiment spécifique particulier
qui est mené sur cette questionl et je
pense
que ça repose essentiellement sur le
principe de la spécialisation
et ce cette cette C cette article est un
peu contradictoire avec tout ce que ce
qu'on essae de développer ce que vous au
ministère de la Justice vous essayez
assez justement de développer merci
Madame aribé l'avis de la commission un
amendement de suppression donc
défavorable avis du
gouvernement je mets au voix ces deux
amendements qui vote
pour qui vote
contre ne sont pas
adoptés amendement numéro amendement
numéro 5 à l'article
3 monsieur
Richard merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministre mes chers
collègues compte tenu de l'utilisation
courante des réseaux de communication ou
d'information par les discours de
radicalisation il me paraît
indispensable de permettre aux
juridictions pour enfant d'interdire à
certains mineurs faisant l'objet de
mesurees de contrôle judiciaire
l'utilisation et l'accès aux réseaux
sociaux c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure dans mon intervention liminaire
le présent amendement propose par
conséquent d'inscrire cette mesure
spéciale parmi les obligations
susceptibles d'intégrer le contrôle
judiciaire mineur je vous
remercie merci quel est l'avis de la
commission oui on comprend parfaitement
l'intention de Monsieur rcharge mais
c'est difficilement opérationnel
particulièrement restrictif j'ajoute et
je lui ai dit en commission que comme
nous avons proposé à l'article 14 de
reprendre une peine complémentaire de
manissement numérique avec les
obligations déjà existantes nous pensons
qu'on est
suffisamment armé en l'occurrence et
qu'il faut pas aller plus loin au risque
d'avoir un problème de proportionn donc
je préférais qu'il reti son amendement
sinon j'y suis
défavorable avis du
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur je formule la même
proposition je rappelle par ailleurs que
le projet de loi qui vise à sécurit à
sécuriser et à réguler l'espace
numérique doit faire l'objet d'une
commission mixte paritaire ce projet est
est plus large que ce que vous
préconisez dans ces conditions je
suggère le le retrait de votre
amendement vous
maintenez le président monsur rapporteur
m'a effectivement dit en commission ce
qu'il vient de dire moi je voudrais
vraiment indiquer
que puisquil a parlé de d'absence de
proportionnalité en fait cet amendement
ne me paraît pas manquer de
proportionnalité pour moi il n'y a pas
d'interdiction générale il reviendrait
naturellement au magistrat de prononcer
l'interdiction concernée dans chaque
affaire selon chaque réseau c'est une
faculté à mon avis
distincte et complémentaire de celle
dont vous me parliez monsieur le
rapporteur à savoir le le bannissement
numérique j'ai bien entendu aussi ce que
ce que me dit monsieur mon le garde des
saau
bon il est clair que le projet de loi
dont dont vous me parlez est important
je trouve quand même que on on on se on
se passerait d'une possibilité donnée au
juges de prononcer cette interdiction et
je je vais consulter comme on dit la
Haute Assemblée je vous remercie donc je
vais mettre au voix cet amendement avec
deux avis défavorables qui vote
pour levez bien la
main qui vote
contre je vais faire un assis de
bout qui vote
pour 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 20 qui vote
contre 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
et pas
adopté je mets au voix l'article
3 qui vote
pour qui vote
contre article 3 est adopté je mets au
voix l'article 4 qui vote pour
qui vote contre qui s'abstient article 4
est adopté l'article 5 est supprimé je
mets au voix l'article 6 qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'article 6 est
adopté reviens à l'article 7 avec un
amendement numéro 15 monsieur
Baroche oui cet article monsieur le
Président avait pour objet de créer a
pour objet de créer une nouvelle mesure
administ
autonome des mesures administratives de
surveillance micass d'interdiction de
paraître dans les grands événements les
mesures administratives de surveillance
adopté lors de la so silte la loi du 30
octobre 2017 prévoit déjà l'obligation
de ne pas se déplacer à l'extérieur de
périmètres géographiques déterminés
obligation de saler ses déplacement
au-delà de périmètres déterminé et
interdiction de paraître en un lieu
déterminé sous couvert du principe de
précaution l'adoption d'E mesure
administrative va inévitablement créer
un risque d'arbitraire pour une partie
de la population dès lors que les
aménagements apportés au droit pénal
permettre de judiciariser plus
précocément les personnes susceptibles
de passer à l'acte terroriste de telles
mesures ne nous semblent pas nécessair
et elle tend à renforcer le bfeuille
législative et sans source de confusion
enfin la législation pénale en matière
de lutte antiterroriste en France étant
extrêmement développé inscrire dans
d'utes droits commun une multitude de
mures administratives coercitiv adopté
dans une logique prédictive fait peser
des menaces sur notre État de droit pour
ces raisons le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire demande la
suppression de cet article et de cette
mesure merci quel est l'avis de la
commission un amendement de suppression
défavorable avis du
gouvernement l'amendement avec deux avis
défavorables de la Commission du
gouvernement je mets au voix cet
amendement qui vote
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas
adopté amendement numéro 35 madame
naraassin
oui merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement euh est un un amendement pour
préciser euh les lieux concernés par
cette interdiction de paraître euh nous
estimons que cette mesure s'inscrit
ouvertement dans la perspective des Jeux
Olympiques et donc il convient de
définir le plus précisément possible le
type d'événement auquel il
s'appliquerait euh et nous nous pensons
que le mieux est que nous précisions que
cette interdiction de paraître soit
déterminée par le par décret sur le
modèle de ce qui existe déjà pour les
grands événements euh notre il y a un
décret grands événements qui est qui a
été mise en place spécifiquement
notamment pour les Jeux Olympiques notre
inquiétude par rapport à l'article tel
qu'il a été rédigé c'est qu'une un
article avec une intention d'application
exceptionnelle ne devienne un un une
mesure d'application
courante quel est l'avis de la
commission alors là nos collègues
socialistes veulent limiter en fait le
champ de l'interdiction de paraître qui
je le rappelle normalement s'applique
que pour les micas créé par l'article 7
bis au seuls grands événements et grands
rassemblement euh ça me paraît non
seulement pas nécessaire mais trop
restrictif je donne un exemple on a
actuellement un tenu de d'un procès
terroriste des complices des du
terroristme qui a commis les attentats
de trèsba de Carcasson ça peut
nécessiter la prise d'interdiction de
paraître à l'encontre de certains
individus si on adopt l'amendement on ne
pourrait pas le faire donc défavorable
avis du
gouvernement je mets au voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorable
qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté amendement numéro 25
monsieur
brossa merci monsieur le Président il
est notamment prévu vu à l'alinéa 5 de
cet article 7 de déroger à la
notification de la personne concernée
par cette interdiction de paraître 48
heures au moins avant son entrée en
vigueur en cas je cite d'urgence dûement
justifié or un peu plus loin dans ce
même article à l'article 7 à l'alinéa 7
la possibilité d'exercer un référé
liberté est expressément prévu à
l'encontre de cette interdiction et un
tel recours laisse justement au juge
administratif 48 heur pour statuer dès
lors et par cohérence avec la garantie
du droit à recour effectif il faut
prévoir de manière systématique une
notification à l'intéressé au plus tard
48 heur avant l'entrée en vigueur de
cette interdiction de paraître sans
qu'une quelconque urgence ne puisse
justifier l'inverse cela est d'autant
plus nécessaire qu'une telle mesure
serait autonome d'une mesure
individuelle de contrôle administratif
et de surveillance c'est le sens de
notre amendement avis de la commission
alors nous avons nous avons pris cet
article parce que nous voulions donner
un caractère beaucoup plus opérationnel
pour un nombre de cas très limités
strictement nécessaires qui sont énoncés
dans l'article pour permettre au
ministre de l'intérieur de la notifier
moins de 48 he avant son entrée en
vigueur mais on a gardé le fait la
contestation devant le juge des référés
meurait possible dans un délai maximum
de 48 heur ce qui permet d'exercer les
droits de recours je suis donc
défavorable à l'amendement avis de
gouvernement deux avis défavorabl je met
au voix cet amendement qui vote
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas adopté
amendement 49 de la
commission rédactionnelle du
gouvernement avis du
gouvernement même avis je mets au voix
qui vote pour qui vote contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté je mets au voix
l'article 7 qui vote pour qui vote
contre qui s'abstient l'article 7 est
adopté article 7 bis suis saisi de deux
amendements identiques monsieur roche
oui monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement de suppression de cet article
7 bis qui a pour objet de rendre
suspensif l'appel a é rejeté par le
ministère de l'Intérieur à l' compte du
jugement d'annulation de renouvellement
des mesures individuelles de contrôle
administrative et de surveillance
l'micass dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
cette mesure donne un pouvoir
disproportionné au magistrat du parquet
d'aller à l'encontre des décisions
d'annulation des magistrats du pôle
antiterroriste alors que ces derniers
souffrent du manque d'indépendance placé
sous la direction et le contrôle de le
chef hiérarchique pour rappel les
jugements d'annulation des micas sont
prononcés lorsqu'il n'existe plus de
raisons sérieus de penser que le
comportement de l'individu constitue une
menace d'une particulière gravité pour
la sécurité et l'ordre public ce sont
des mesures particulièrement
attentatoire aux libertés individuelles
de nature apporté à tête à la liberté
d'aller et venir il doit donc être
laissé à l'appréciation du magistrat
l'opportunité de battre fait ou non à de
telles mesures sans assortir leur
décision de quelconque effit susp offif
la prévention des actes de terrorisme
est un objectif légitime qu'il ne s'agit
dulement de contester pour autant cet
article assque l'ensemble de ce texte en
rognant sur les libertés individuelles
sans apporter de garantie au
justiciables témoine d'une dérive
inquiétante répondant à une logique de
suspicion qui a pénétré notre État de
droit merci Madame Nara sigin merci
monsieur le Président dans la droite
ligne de ce que vient d'expliquer mon
collègue
benaroche pendant les travaux de la
commission le rapporteur a souhaité
conférir un caractère suspensif à
l'appel interjeté par le ministère de
l'Intérieur à l'encontre des du demicass
du du pardon de l'encontte du jugement
d'annulation du renouvellement d'une
micass l'argument selon lequel ce n'est
pas grave puisqueaprès tout il est
statut en appel dans un délé de 72 he ne
tient pas comme le rapporteur l'explique
en objet de son amendement en commission
lorsque le tribunal administratif annule
la mesure de renouvellement la
surveillance de l'intérêté prend fin y
compris si le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des autres Maes relève appel du jugement
et en réalité on ne voit pas pourquoi il
devrait en être autrement puisque dans
notre pays en effet ce sont encore les
tribunaux qui décident de ce genre de
chose merci avis de la
commission défavorable défvorable avis
du gouvernement mais ma vie je mets au
voix ces amendements qui vote
pour qui vote
contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adoptés un amendement de la commission
nel amendement rédactionnel favorable je
mets au voix cet amendement qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté je mets au voix l'article 7
qui vote pour qui vote contre qui
s'abstient l'article 7 est adopté
article
7 amendement 45 madame Nara sigin
merci monsieur le Président avec cet
amendement de suppression nous tenons à
faire remarquer deux choses qui sont
rlatrice à la fois de la dynamique de
cette proposition de loi mais aussi d'un
mouvement qui ces dernières années va
toujours dans le même sens le rapporteur
a expliqué l'insertion de cet article
par la présence d'une malalefçon dans la
loi du 30 juillet
2021 lorsqu'on veut légiférer aussi
régulièrement et aussi rapidement sur
ces questions doit-on se plaindre d'y
trouver ensuite des malfaçons monsieur
le rapporteur vous souhaitez une voie de
recours à l'encontre de la décision du
juge des libertés et de la détention du
refus d'exploitation de documents et de
données saisies dans le cadre d'une
visite domiciliaire permettez-nous de
dire que cette hypothèse doit être assez
rare pour être amplement justifiée vous
ne pourrez pas niz que dans ces
propositions vous passez désormais votre
temps à vouloir limiter l'office du juge
mais jusqu'ù et jusqu'à quand merci
l'avis de la commission amendement de
suppression défavorable du
gouvernement je mets au voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorable
qui vote pour qui vote contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté je mets
au voix l'article 7 TER qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient l'
article 7 ter est adopté article 7 quat
je saisi d'un amendement numéro 17
monsieur Baroche oui monsieur le
Président je vais aller dans le même
sens il s'agit encore d'une suppression
d'article cette fois-ci c'est le 7
quatur qui a pour objet de renforcer la
transmission des informations quant à la
prise en charge d'une personne
radicalisé hospitalisé sans son
consentement au préfet du lieu
d'hospitalisation et du lieu de domicile
le Syndicat de la magistrature avait
souligné lors de l'examen de la loi
relative à la prévention d'actes de
terrorisme au renseignement que ces
disposition marque une étape
supplémentaire et significative dans le
fichage et la surveillance des personnes
souffrant de troubles psychiatriques
toujours selon le Syndicat de la
magistrature le secret médical est un
principe fondamental de l'exercice de la
médecine et son respect découle des
exigen du 11e alinéat du Préambule de la
Constitution du 25 octobre 1946 relative
à la protection de la santé sans
confiance des patients envers leurs
médecins par crainte de la diffusion de
données médicales l'incitation à aller
se soigner se trouve dangereusement
altéré alors même que le code de
déontologie médicale prévoit que le
secret médical est institué dans
l'intérêt des patients et pour préserver
la confiance dans le corps médical pour
ces raisons notre groupe s'oppose à
cette mesure l'avis de la commission
amendement de suppression défavorable du
gouvernement
je mets au voix cet amendement avec deux
avis défavorables qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté je mets au voix
l'article 7 qu qui vote pour qui vote
contre qui s'abstient article quatè est
adopté article 8 saisi de deux
amendements identiques le
26 monsieur
brossa merci monsieur le président
monsieur le garde des SA cet article est
celui qui a le plus attiré notre
attention il modifie les conditions de
dissolution administratives des
associations en précisant la la notion
de provocation pouvant justifier une
telle mesure cela dépasse largement le
cadre de la seule lutte contre le
terrorisme car tel qu'il est rédigé cet
article 8 modifie l'article
l2121 du code de sécurité intérieure qui
porte le régime de dissolution de toutes
les associations et groupement de faits
si l'islamisme est la mouvance la plus
concernée par ces mesures avec 9
dissolutions sur 46 depuis 2012 aucune
d'entre elles n'a été suspendue ou
annulée en justice à vrai dire sur ces
46 dissolutions seul deux ont été
suspendus en justice et deux autres
annulés dont celles visant les
soulèvements de la terre on peut dès
lors convenir que 4/ 46 ce n'est pas
exactement ce qu'on pourra appeler un
gouvernement des juges expression qui
revient de manière récurrente dans le
débat public d'une façon pour le moins
confuse c'est pourquoi nous ne
comprenons pas la volonté de je cite
moderniser renforcer selon les mots de
l'exposé des motifs du présent texte ce
régime de dissolution administrative
plus généralement le rapport de novembre
dernier de l'Assemblée nationale sur
l'activisme violent soulève plusieurs
limites au principe même d'une telle
mesure pour toutes ces raisons nous
demandons la supprpression de cet
article quel est l'avis de la
commission amendement de suppression
défavorable mais on va
faire vous allez présenter votre amend
quand même c'est deux amendement
identiques oui j'ai monsieur le
Président j'ai peu ajouté après
l'argumentaire l'exc argumentaire de de
monsieur bressa nous demandons également
la suppression de ces dispositions
puisque nous estimons qu'elle ne relève
pas de l'objet de ce texte qui doit être
dédié au terrorisme et que l'article cet
article touche bien au-delà à la
question des associations bien sur la
commission c'est
toujours c'est ça je mets au voix ces
deux amendements avec deux avis
défavorables qui vote pour qui vote
contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adoptés deux amendement en discussion
commune monsieur brossa pourou le
27 merci monsieur le Président il s'agit
d'un amendement de replil de notre
amendement de suppression nous proposons
ici de ne supprimer que les dispositions
de l'article qui touche aux modalités de
dissolution administrative des
associations et groupement de fait sans
revenir sur celle qui instiue un régime
de dévolution des biens de ces
associations dis toute ajouté en
commission je vous remercie amandement
de la commission oui monsieur le
Président maises chers collègues nous
avons euh pris soin dans cette rédaction
de reprendre les termes utilisés par le
Conseil d'État dans sa récente
jurisprudence sur les soulèvements de la
terre donc on ne fait que graver dans le
marbre de la loi une définition
jurisprudentielle pour sécuriser
l'action des services du ministère de
l'Intérieur et mon amendement suivant
est un amendement de simplification qui
permet de rendre la la rédaction plus
lisible donc défavorable sur celui de
Monsieur brossa et favorable sur le mien
mais ma avis donc je mets au voix le 27
avec deux avis défavorables qui vote
pour qui vote
contre il n'est pas
adopté amendement 51 avec deux avis
favorables qui vote pour qui vote
contre qui s'abstient l'amend numéro 51
est adopté amendement numéro 18 monsieur
Baroche monsieur le Président ça nous
paraît être un amendement
important en fait nous souhaitons
consolider la jurisprudence du Conseil
d'État dont vient de parler le
rapporteur Conseil d'État qui dans sa
jurisprudence distingue les violences
contre les biens et les violences contre
les
personnes suite aux manifestations de C
Soline le ministre de l'Intérieur
avait qualifié les manifestants
d'écoterroristes et entamé une verdicte
à l'encte du mouvement les soulèvements
de la terre remettant également en cause
les travaux et le financement de la
Ligue des droits de
l'Homme notre groupe a toujours défendu
la liberté associativ et sdical toutes
nous avons toujours aussi déploré
l'acharnement qu'on subit de manière
déraisonnable et disproportionnée
certaines
associations cet amendement que nous
proposons nous paraît essentiel à
l'équilibre des droits des associations
car il limite l'arbitraire avec lequel
l'État s'attaque à certaines
manifestations nous sommes
stupéfait de voir que la minimisation de
certains faits par le ministre
l'acceptation de certaines dégradations
ben rien que cette semaine monsieur le
ministre nous avons assisté à une
explosion revendiquée qui a soufflé le
bâtiment de la Direction de
l'Environnement à
Carcassonne à un blocage des train à AG
avec déversement de pneus et fumiers sur
les loi
Ferré donc toutes les actions ne se
valent pas si je comprends bien en tout
cas juridiquement elle devrai nous
souhaitons garantir au maximum la
possibilité pour toutes les colères de
s'exprimer de protéger des tentatives de
dissolution arbitraire de certaines des
associations de désobéissance civil qui
organisent des actions d'occupation qui
ne véhiculent pas de haine qui ne
commettent pas de violence envers les
personnes ou envers un groupe de
personnes à l'image des dernières
déclarations du ministre Gérald armanin
nous comprenons que des actions menées
par ces associations blocus occupation
de lieu ne peuvent être qualifié comme
des agissements troublant gravement
l'ordre public nous souhaitons donc que
cette latitude d'expression accordée aux
agriculteurs ces derniers jours puisse
bénéficier à l'ensemble des
revendication portées et pas seulement
pour ceux qui sont soutenus
politiquement par le
pouvoir merci quel est l'avis de la
commission autant autant la le fait de
graver dans la loi la définition euh
novatrice d'ailleurs de la provocation
telle qu'elle a été définie dans dans la
jurisprudence du Conseil d'État nous
semble nécessaire autant la nécessité
pour l'administration comme vous le
proposez de prendre des décisions
adaptées nécessair et proportionné n'
rien de nouveau c'est c'est superflu ça
va de soi et ça ne change pas et ça ne
changera pas donc c'est défavorable avis
du
gouvernement je mets au voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui votent
pour qui vote contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté je
mets au voix l'article 8 qui vote pour
qui vote contre qui s'abstient l'article
8 est adopté après l'article 8 je suis
saisi d'un amendement de Madame Nathalie
Goulet oui monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre la mémoire m'est
revenue ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle dans le texte merci dans le
texte sur les principes de la République
nous avions nous avions nous avions
ajouté à la liste des bien qui devait
être listé les parts de société civile
immobilière euh pour les biens des
associations et leur contrôle le Sénat
avait adopté cette mesure qui a ensuite
sauté en commission mixte paritaire
c'est la raison pour laquelle
conformément à la jurisprudence du Sénat
je souhaite que de nouveau ces part de
SCI figure dans les biens des
associations d'autant que c'est une
demande expresse de tracf notamment dans
son dernier rapport sur l'état de la
menace je vous remercie quel l'avis de
la commission oui ça va tout à fait dans
dans le sens et dans l'état d'esprit de
la commission donc avis
favorable avis du
gouvern
sagesse commission d'accord je vais
mettre au voix cet amendement avec un
avis favorable de la commission sagesse
du gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement est
adopté article 8 encore amendement 11 de
Madame Nathalie Goulet euh oui monsieur
le Président mieurs les ministres dans
dans le même texte nous avions demandé
l'assujétissement des cagnottes en ligne
euh aux obligations notamment de
contrôle de de Tracfin le Sénat avait
adopté cette disposition qui avait sauté
en commission mixte paritaire puis a été
intégré dans la loi grâce à une
directive européenne néanmoins l'article
561 23 du Code Monétaire et Financier
fisse une limite à ce contrôle or nous
avons en ce moment beaucoup oup de
difficultés avec les cagnotes en ligne
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
souhaite voir supprimer le second alinéa
de l'article L 561 2 3 du Code Monétaire
et Financier avis de la commission même
avis favorable pour les mêmes
raisons favorable pour la commission
sagesse je mets au voix pour le
gouvernement je mets au voix cet
amendement qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement est adopté article 9 je
suis saisi de trois amendements
identiques monsieur benaroche pour le 19
oui monsieur le Président j'ai j'ai
envie de dire c'est le P ça en fait
quelque part l'article 9 en fait qu'on
veut supprimer il a pour objet de
faciliter la levée de protection contre
l'éloignement dont bénéficie certaines
catégories d'étrangers bon quand même il
faut noter que cette mesure est déjà
inscrite dans la loi immigration et
intégration adopté à l'Assemblée
nationale 19 décembre
2023 mais qu'elle est en attente du
jugement du Conseil constitutionnel qui
doit avoir lieu le 25 janvier
2024 et donc la majorité sénatoriale
juge bon de réintroduire cette
disposition dans la présente proposition
de loi de peur ou pour marquer son
territoire que cette dernière fasse
l'objet d'une censure du Conseil
constitutionnel moi je trouve avec
certains de mes collègues de tout bord
comme nous l'avions trouvé lors de la
loi immigration sur les articles
anticonstitutionnels y compris à
l'Assemblée nationale qu'il n'est pas
concevable que le Parlement introduise
dans un texte de loi à nouveau bis
repétita non
plaquette des mesures de peur que
celle-ci soit jugée attentatoire au
liberté individuelle et écarté par le
Conseil constitutionnel on en arrive là
quand même on va voter un article parce
qu'on se dit ah ben le Conseil
constitutionnel il va pas l'accepter
donc nous on va le revoter on sait
jamais bon de tels procédés pour moi
illustrent uniquement l'atention
d'affichage politique de ces lois
sécuritaires en dépit de toute réflexion
sur leur validité juridique je demande
la suppression de cet article monsieur
bossa merci amendement identique et et
arguments
similaires Mame narassin
oui je l'ai déjà expliqué en dans la
discussion générale le fait que la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel n'it
pas été rendu n'a pas être prise en
compte monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
argué en commission que la PPL avait été
écrite avant l'adoption de la loi
immigration euh mais il y a rien qui
vous empêche de supprimer aujourd'hui
ces dispositions qui sont parfaitement
inutiles avis de la commission il n a
rien qui m'empêche de faire le contraire
non plus c'est un amendement de
suppression défavorable habis du
gouvernement je mets au voix ces trois
amendements avec deux avis défavorables
qui vote
pour qui vote contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptés
amendement
23 madame diolco oui merci président par
ce par cet amendement madame stage
brigot entend fluidifier la procédure de
consultation de la commission
d'expulsion qui est prévu au cza
premièrement il s'agit de réduire de 15
à 10 jours le délai entre la mise du la
remise du bulletin de convocation et la
réunion de la commission et deuxièmement
il s'agit de prévoir que la Commission
d'expulsion doit rendre son avis dans un
délai Maxim
jours à compé de sa réunion je vous
remercie avis de la commission
oui c'est un amendement tout à fait
utille la commission d'expulsion est un
passage obligé pour permettre aux
étrangers de se défendre s'ils sont sous
le coup d'une expulsion les délis
actuels crent lourdeur
inutile voire dangereuse s'agissant de
l'éloignement d'étranger qui menace
gravement l'ordre public donc réduire un
17 jours est une mesure de bon sens avis
très favorable favorable avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre je mis
au voix cet amendement avec deux avis
favorables qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement est adopté amendement 6
monsieur
Richard si monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues cet amendement a pour seul
objectif de garantir un accomplissement
complet de la durée d'interdiction du
territoire en cas de retour
irrégulier alors je sais bien ce que va
me répondre monsieur le rapporteur
puisqu'il me l'a dit tout à l'heure en
commission je voudrais préciser que en
cas de violation de l'interdiction du
territoire français des sanctions
pénales et une nouvelle interdiction du
territoire français peuTent
effectivement être prononcé monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez 1000 fois raison
par contre la reconduction automatique
de cette interdiction du territoire
français n'est pas encore prévue dans le
droit positif à l'heure actuelle au
niveau législatif c'est le but de cet
amendement c'est permettre une
automaticité du prolongation de la peine
d'interdiction du territoire français en
cas de retour irrégulier je vous
remercie l' vie de la commission
oui j'ai bien compris l'intention qui
est qui est louable mais je le redis le
droit existant prévoit que l'entrée sur
le territoire français en violation
d'une ITF est passible de 3 ans de
prison et d'une nouvelle peine d'ITF qui
peut aller jusqu'à 10 ans et donc je
pense qu'il est satisfait et donc avis
défavorable je préférais qu'il soit
retiré je mets au voix cet amendement
avec deux avis défavorables qui vote
[Musique]
pour qui vote
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté je mets au voix l'article 9 qui
vote pour qui vote
contre qui s'abstient l'article 9 fait
adopté l'article 10 je suis saisi de
deux amendements identiques 20 le 20
monsieur bénaroche oui monsieur le
Président comme pour l'article 9 il
s'agit d'unamandement de suppression de
cet article pour les mêmes raisons
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait cet article il
reprend l'article 73 du projet de la loi
immigration intégration adopté le 19
décembre
2023 qui prévoit d'autoriser le recours
à un dispositif de de contradictoire
asymétrique devant le juge administratif
pour le jugement de décisions fondé sur
des motifs en lien avec la prévention
d'actes de terrorisme là encore il y a
recours près du Conseil constitutionnel
et là encore nous attendons la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel sur ce texte
et sur cet article et de nouveau la
majorité sénatoriale souhaite
réintroduire cette disposition de peur
de sa censure par le Conseil
constitutionnel je rajouterai par
rapport à tout à l'heure que ce procédé
risque d'une part de nuire à la
lisibilité de la loi pénale avec un
effet doublant des mesures si elles sont
adoptées et validées par le Conseil
constitutionnel dans les deux textes et
en second lieu il n'est pas concevable
que le Parlement introduise dans une
nouvelle proposition de loi une mesure
qui serait jugée attentatoire aux
libertés individuelles et écartée par le
Conseil constitutionnel je vous demande
donc chers collègu de voter l'amendement
de
suppression merci Monsieur
brossa défendu
avis de la commission avis de
suppression
défavorable je mets au voix ces deux
amendements avec deux avis
défavorableable qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient ils
ne sont pas adopté je mets au voix
l'article 10 qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'article 10 est adopté article 10 bis
qui saisit de deux amendements
identiques monsieur
benaroche
alors cet amendement vise à supprimer
l'article 10 l'article 10 son objet
c'est déétendre la possibilité de
prolonger jusqu'à 210 jours la rétention
administrative d'un étranger faant
l'objet d'une mesure d'expulsion et
dictée en raison d'une provocation
directe à des actes de terrorisme ou de
leur apologie pénalement
constatée ici le rôle du placement en
centre de tion administrative et dévoyé
et de plus en plus assimilé à de la
détention nombre d'entre elles font
ainsi plusieurs allers-retours entre ces
deux lieux d'enfermement en 2019 plus de
3200 personnes ont été amenés en centre
de rétention administratif à leur
sortant à leur sortie de prison et près
de 300 ont été envoyés devant le
tribunal correctionnel à partir de ces
mêmes centres des chiffres en
augmentation depuis plusieurs années
selon la CB de de l'enfermement
suto-entretien elle maintient en dehors
du droit celles et ceux qui sont
considérés comme indésirables avant de
les plonger dans un engrenage dont il
est impossible de sortir plus les
personnes sont précarisées plus elles se
retrouvent réprimées et plus elles sont
réprimées plus elles sont
précarisé parce que le centre de
rétention administrative n'a pas pour
but premier de neutraliser les personnes
suspecté de
dangerosité parce que le placement en
centre de rétention administrative
contrairement à la peine d' prisonnement
n'a pas de visée punitive mais décidé
dans un objectif d'éloignement des
personnes en situation irrégulière notre
groupe demande la suppression de cet
article madame narassigin
oui nous demandons également la
suppression de cet article puisque une
fois encore on étend le champ des
mesures exceptionnelles quel est le sens
de multiplier les candidats potentiels à
une rétention administrative de 210
jours nous demandons encore la
suppression donc de cet article parce
que progressivement la rétention
administrative est détournée de son
usage pour durer de plus en plus
longtemps et s'appliquer à de plus en
plus de monde et se substituer à la
détention ce qui n'est pas normal et
n'est pas souhaitable dans un état de
droit quel est l'avis de la commission
amendement de suppression défavorable
avis du
gouvernement je mets au voix ces deux
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui vote pour qui vote contre qui
s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adoptés article
10 madame Difalco diolco diolco merci
euh notre collègue madameage brigot
souhaite attirer notre attention sur le
fait que la combinaison des articles
l742-6 et
l742-7 du code du czda notutorise la
prolongation jusqu'à 210 jours de la
rétention administrative d'étrangers
faisant l'objet d'une décision
d'expulsion pour des activités à
caractère terroriste que lorsque ces
dernières ont été pénalement constatées
toutefois l'arrêté d'expulsion a le
caractère d'une mesure de police
administrative et sont prononcé et de
jurisprudence constante indépendant
d'une condamnation pénale il est donc
paradoxal que ce critère qui n'est
d'ailleurs pas mentionné dans la
directive retour soit pris en compte
pour la prolongation de la rétention
administrative désintéressé il s'agit
donc d'un amendement de cohérence je
vous
remercie merci l' VI de la la commission
oui c'est une nouvelle fois une mesure
opérationnelle tout à fait efficace avis
favorable avis du gouvernement je mets
au voix cet amendement avec deux avis
favorables qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté je mets au voix l'article 10
bis qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
article 10 bis est adopté article 11
qui saisit de deux amendements
identiques monsieur
benaroch un amendement de suppression de
l'article 22 article pardon article 11
article 11 qui a pour
objet de consacrer le délit de recelle
d'apologie du terrorisme permettant de
sanctionner les individus détenant de
telles images apologétiques sans volonté
de
diffusion saisi du question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité le Conseil
constitutionnel avait censuré ce délit
au motif qu'il portait la tête à
l'exercice de la liberté de
communication qui n'est pas nécessaire
adapté et proportionné c'est une
décision du 15 du QPC du du 15 décembre
2017 la majorité sénatoriale tente
d'introduire à nouveau cette mesure en
l'assortisseant de quelques garanties
elle a pourtant été déjà jugée
attentatoire aux libertés individuell
écartée par le Conseil constitutionnel
de tel procédés illustre pour nous la se
attention d'affichage politique en dépit
de toute réflexion sur leur validité
juridique je peux pas m'empêcher du coup
de rappeler quand même une citation d'un
président de la République vous vous en
souviendrez tous lorsqu'on consulte des
images de djihadiste on est un
djihadiste et on doit être traité comme
tel président
Sarkozi merci Madame Nar
oui nous demandons la la la suppression
de la réintroduction du délit de recelle
d'apologie du terrorisme à propos duquel
le Conseil constitutionnel a déjà eu
l'occasion de se prononcer et sa réponse
était extrêmement claire il porte une
atteinte qui n'est ni nécessaire ni
adaptée ni proportionnée à la liberté
d'expression et de
communication nous remarquons que les
auteurs de la PPL prétendent encadrer
cette infraction en la caractérisant si
elle s'accompagne d'une adhésion à
l'idéologie exprimée dans les documents
en question une fois encore il est fait
appel à cette fameuse adhésion à
l'idéologie le recours à cette
expression n'est vraiment pas gage de
sécurité et d'efficacité pour la loi
pénale ce n'est pas en adossant
progressivement de plus en plus
d'infractions et de sanctions à ce
critère de l'adhésion idéologique que
nous rendrons la loi plus intelligible
mieux applicable et protectrice merci
quel est l'avis de la commission c'est
un amendement de suppression mais comme
j'ai l' expliqué dans la discussion
général il y a effectivement eu une
décision du Conseil constitutionnel qui
exprime ses motivations nous avons
repris ses motivations et adapté
l'article en conséquence donc avis
défavorable à la suppression m avis deux
avis défavorable ou ces amendements
sagesse avis de sagesse du gouvernement
avis défavorable de la commission je
mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote
contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adoptés je mets au voix l'article 11 qui
vote
pour qui vote contre
qui s'abstient article 11 est adopté
article 11 B amendement de la commission
monsieur le rappor
rédactionnelle favorable je mets au voix
cet amendement qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui
s'abstientamendement est adopté je mets
au voix l'article 11 B qui vote pour qui
vote contre qui s'abstient l'article 11
bis est adopté l'article 12 amendement
43 oui monsieur le Président nous
demandons la la suppression de cet
article à deux titres la provocation à
des actes de terrorisme être combattu et
réprimé de manière égale partout d'où
qu'ell vienneent nous la jugeons
suffisamment grave pour ne pas la
distinguer selon le lieu dans laquel
cette pardon provocation est commise
deuxièmement les magistrats n'ont pas
besoin de nous pour être sévère et
appliquer la loi nous avons basculé dans
une véritable inflation de la loi pénale
qui finira par désorgan son équilibre à
terme n'y a-t-il pas d'autre solution
plus efficace que l'ajout d'une
circonstance aggravante dans le code
pénal même si nous avons à faire
aujourd'hui à un texte qui rêve de
justice prédictive il faut aussi
rappeler et accepter que généralement et
ce depuis toujours le droit pénal
arriêve trop tard sa vocation est d'agir
à postériori chers collègues
proposerez-vous que proposerez-vous une
fois que toutes les peines auront été
portter à leur
maximum l'avis de la commission
oui je rappelle à nos collègues que il
s'agit là de reprendre une préconisation
du rapport de la commission d'enquête de
2018 qui avait été conduit au Sénat avec
Madame Stach brigot et que donc nous
avons repris une des préconisations de
la commission d'enquête quand les
sénateurs font des commissions d'enquête
généralement c'est pour qu'on puisse
mettre autant que faire ce peu dans la
loi leur préconisation donc il est hors
de question que j'enlève cette très
bonne suggestion de Madame stage brigot
avis défavorable avis de du gouver
sagesse l'avis défavorable de la
commission sagesse du gouvernement qui
vote
pour qui vote
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté je mets au voix l'article 12 qui
vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'article 12 est adopté l'article 13 est
supprimé je mets au voix l'article 14
qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'article 14 est adopté article 15
madame Nara sigin pour l'amendement
44 mes chers collègues nous nous
comprenons l'intention qui préside à la
rédaction de cet article et que les
choses soient bien claires nous
soutenons nous aussi la protection des
transports en commun toutefois cette
peine complémentaire d'interdiction de
paraître dans un ou plusieurs réseaux de
transport public nous semble inopportune
avec la même logique on pourrait
décliner à l'infini des nouvelles peines
complémentaires à partir de toutes les
infractions existantes il y a bien
d'autres façons de protéger ces espaces
nous n'avons pas établir des peines
complémentaire
automatique si le but est d'être
efficace il n'y a pas de terroristes des
transports et des terroristes de
supermarché des terroristes donc voilà
donc il y a une certaine absurdité à cet
article et c'est pour cela que nous
demandons sa
suppression avis de la
commission avis défavorable avis du
gouvernement sagesse sagesse je mets au
voix cet amendement avec un avis
défavorable de la commission sagesse du
gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas adopté amendement
numéro 8 de Monsieur
Richard merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur les ministres mes chers
collègues cet amendement a pour objectif
de clarifier la portée de la peine
complémentaire de paraître dans un ou
plusieurs réseaux de transport public il
propose simplement de retenir
l'expression moyen de transport à la
place des expressions véhicules affectés
au transport collectif de voyageurs ou
moyen de transport public je vous
remercie quelle est la commission oui
j'exliqu à monsieurchard qu'on a déjà eu
ce débat en 2021 et qu'on avait pour
éviter un risque de
disproportionnalité adopter une
rédaction qui est donc dans le dans le
texte je me propose de nous en tenir à
cette rédaction déjà votée par le Sénat
donc avis défavorable sur celui-là sur
l'autre j'aurais un autre avis avis du
gouvernement défavorable avis
défavorables l'amendement est retiré
donc l'amendement numéro 7 monsieur
richard-y cet amendement a pour objectif
d'améliorer la sanction de de violations
d'une interdiction de paraître dans le
transport en commun en assortissant
cette sanction d'une inscription au
fichier des personnes recherchées avec
naturellement la mention spéciale
correspondante je vous remercie l'avis
de la commission on l'avait pas encore
évoqué je pense que monsieur richchard a
raison parce que ça renforce fortement
l'opérationnalité du dispositif avis
favorable je mets en voie cet amendement
avec un avis favorable de la commission
sagesse du gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement est adopté je mets au voix
l'article 15 qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'article 15 est adopté article après
l'article 15 amendement numéro 9
monsieur
Richard merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues cet amendement a pour objectif
de créer une peine complémentaire
d'interdiction de paraître dans les
lieux et équipements sportifs vous
l'avez
compris c'est à la fois dans l'optique
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
mais de façon plus globale sur tous les
les lieux et équipements sportifs même
en l'absence de ces grands événements
avis de la commission oui évidemment
nous sommes penchés sur ce sujet j'ai
déjà expliqué qu'à l'article 7 nous
avions pris une nouvelle disposition
avec une interdiction de paraître qui
est plus générale qui nous semble plus
facile à motiver donc plus efficiente
donc je préférais que Monsieur monsieur
rchard retire son amendement puisque on
a anticipé le sujet à l'article 7 avis
défavorable sinon avis du gouvernement
deux avis défavorables monsieur
oui j'aurais voulu plaider ma cause une
seconde auprès de monsieur le rapporteur
et de Monsieur le Ministre en fait j'ai
bien compris puisque monsieur le
rapporteur a indiqué ça ce matin en
commission des lois ou cet après-midi en
commission des lois que les champs
d'application de l'article 7 et de cet
amendement sont proches mais pour autant
je viens de le dire ne correspondent pas
tout à fait si la sécurisation des
grands événements en cas de menaces
grave est effectivement satisfaite grâce
monsieur le rapporteur à à votre
intervention sur l'article 7 cet article
7 exclut la possibilité d'interdire
l'accès aux équipements et installations
sportives en temps normal c'est cet
élargissement que cet amendement propose
prenons prenons le cas d'un match de
foot traditionnel le championnat dans la
mesure
où les les les faits ont été commis dans
un lieu allez pour prendre Strasbourg au
Racing Club de Strasbourg à
laaméo il paraîtrait peut-être logique
que en dehors de grands événements même
s'il y en a beaucoup à Strasbourg il y
ait possibilité de faire une
interdiction de paraître dans cette
enceinte en temps normal lors des matchs
traditionnels le championnat je vous
remercie vous le retirez ou d'accord
mais je mets
oui que le rapporteur me me dise si cet
article 7 couvre effectivement les cas
dont je viens de parler un match de foot
normal en championnat est-il couvert par
l'article 7 je ne le pense pas et
pourtant ça me paraîtrait
important pour leur je redit les choses
si on est avec un match de football pour
prendre l'exemple de la meno et qui a un
risque terroriste avéré oui mon article
7 le couvre mais sinon on a on va pas
pouvoir prendre une mesure de ce type on
va avoir un problème de
disproportionnalité on aura on va se
faire retoquer en l'occurrence bon et
par ailleurs j'essais toujours j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure de rendre les
choses pour qu'on ne vienne pas porter
ombrage au micass qui sont des mesures
très efficaces et qu'il faut pas qu'on
ait superposition le garde des saau l'a
dit lui-même tout à l'heure et j'ai
essayé en permanence d'éviter ce
chevenchement pour qu'on garde
l'efficacité des micas voilà pourquoi je
suis obligé de dire défavorable
l'amendement
retiré article 15 bis amendement 53 de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
alors il a son importance cet article 15
bis puisque dans dans tout ce qui
concernait le la loi d vigal pour les
par des condamnés terroristes on a on a
dû parce qu'il y a eu des détournements
abusifs reprendre un certain nombre de
choses donc je précise quand il y a
changement de de nom qu'on peut aller
plus loin et donc il y a quatre ob
objectif élargir le dispositif au
changement de prénom garantir la saisine
systématique par l'officier de l'état
civil du procureur de la République
compétent garantir l'unicité des
documents justifiant de l'identité et
prévenir des problèmes sécuritaires liés
à une double identité et ajouter au
titre des obligations des personnes
inscrites au fichier des auteurs
d'infraction terroriste l'obligation de
déclarer tout changement de nom et de
prénom pour éviter que les terroristes
ne détournent à leur profit la loi sur
changement de nom merci donc évidemment
c'est un amendement de la commission et
nous y sommes favorables pour une
explication de vote on va demander
l'avis du
Gouvernement favorable madame Nar oui
merci monsieur le Président nous ne nous
opposerons pas ni ni à cet article ni ni
à cet amendement
cependant je tiens à souligner au nom du
du groupe socialiste que nous avons une
inquiétude générale par rapport à à
l'intention qu'il y a derrière cet
amendement il n'y a pas de n nous
opposerons pas parce que nous ne sommes
pas opposés à ce qu'il est une
information systématique du procureur et
que ça reste bien au procureur de
prendre la décision et donc nous voulons
rappeler que son rôle n'est évidemment
pas de faire obstacle à euh des volonté
de réintégration de réinsertion qui
peuvent être tout à fait sincères et qui
et ce que qui peuvent à quoi les
changements de nom peuvent aussi euh
être utile après une condamnation et ne
pas partir du principe que tout personne
condamnée va
récidiver
merercier monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur monsieur les ministre bien
évidemment nous allons voter cet
amendement parce que lors de l'examen de
la loi du 1er Juillet 2022 nous avions
alerté justement sur cette possibilité
de changement de nom qui peut se faire
de façon très simple en mairie mais
aussi sur demande et là cela concerne
concerne le figet mais je voudrais vous
signaler le cas de Francis Érard ce
violeur multirécidiviste qui a violé le
le petit Enis et qui vient de changer de
nom en prison il a pris le nom de sa
maman ce qui fait que Francis Érard
n'apparaît plus maintenant sur le
fichier sur le figes donc je félicite
évidemment la rédaction de cet
amendement et nous en reparlerons en ce
qui concerne le
figè merci je mets au voix cet
amendement avec deux avis favorables qui
vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement est adopté l'article est
ainsi
rédigé article 15
TER
Mame narassa
oui euh nous nous demandons la
suppression de l'information obligatoire
de l'autorité académique et du du chef
d'établissement euh d'une mise en examen
ou d'une condamnation pour infraction
terroriste y compris d'apologie d'une
personne scolarisée ou ayant vocation à
scolariser dans l'établissement Scola
public ou privé euh cette cette mesure
on peut en comprendre l'intention hein
mais mais cette mesure pourrait en
réalité avoir des effets
contreproductifs et néfastes euh à
partir de quel moment euh à partir du
moment où vous informez un chef
d'établissement de la sorte vous faites
porter sur ce chef d'établissement une
responsabilité qui n'est pas la sienne
euh que dirait-on que que ferait-on que
reprocherait-on un chef d'établissement
si un de ces élèves commettait un crime
alors qu'il a été informé donc monsieur
le rapporteur vous vous sez expressément
l'apologie dans l'objet de votre
amendement de commission or voilà
l'exemple d'une infraction qui pourrait
par exemple être facilement reprochée à
des légions de collégiens euh
faudrait-il mettre en place des fichiers
prévoir la déscolarisation de sûreté euh
soit on est condamné soit euh on ne
l'est pas soit on est libre soit on ne
l'est pas soit on a quelque chose à
reprocher soit on a rien fait et donc
vous êtes en train de brouiller toutes
les lignes et tous les principes et je
voudrais souligner qu'il y a notamment
un rapport de Monsieur Pillet que vous
qu'on connaît bien dans cette dans cette
assemblée qui avait mise en garde contre
ce type de
mesure merci l'avis de la commission
amendement de suppression donc
défavorable avis du gouvernement je mets
au voix cet amendement avec deux avis
défavorables qui vote pour qui vote
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté amendement 42
oui il s'agit d'un d'un amendement de
repli par rapport à ce que je viens de
vous exposer pour l'amendement précédent
mais nous demandons cette fois de
supprimer très spécifiquement le cas de
la mise en examen l'information
obligatoire dans un tel cas de figure
est un un baffement total de la
présomption d'innocence avis du de la
Commission oui c'est contraire à la
position de la Commission qu'on a
défendu la semaine dernière avis
défavorable du gouvernement avis du
gouvernement je mets au voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui vote pour qui vote contre qui
s'abstient l'amendement n'est pas adopté
je mets au voix l'article 15 TER qui
vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'article 15 ter est adopté après
l'article 15 qui saisit d'un amendement
madame Goulet ou ou monsieur le
Président Monsieur le ministreagit D'
amendement du du président Marseille
l'article 6133 du code de la sécurité
intérieure prévoit la possibilité de
recours au dispositif d'imagerie
utilisant des ondes millimétriques pour
la sécurisation des sites et enceintes
dans lesquelles sont organisées des
manifestations sportives récréative ou
culturel rassemblant plus de 300
spectateurs cet amendement vise à
permettre à des sociétés d'utiliser une
technologie innovante basé sur les ones
centimétriques et pas seulement
millimétriques pour pour la sécurisation
des sites et événements rassemblant plus
de 300 personnes c'est un amendement de
précision rédigé au millimètre par le
président Marseille merci l'avis de la
commission le président Marseille a
raison de considérer que les ondes
centimétriques sont nettement moins
intrusives quand on les utilise que les
ondes millimétriques et donc ça rend le
dispositif d'autant plus opérationnel
avis
favorable avis du
gouvernement
je voudrais que le le sénateur de Bress
puisse nous détailler un peu la
différence entre les deux mais en
attendant jeai un avis de
sagesse je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement avec un avis favorable de la
commission avis de sagesse du
gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement est
adopté je mets au voix l'article 16 qui
vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'article 16 est adopté mes chers
collègues nous avons terminé l'examen
des articles de ce texte je vous
rappelle que les explications de vote et
le vote par scrutin public sur
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi se
dérouleront le mardi 30 janvier je vais
suspendre la séance quelques instants
afin de permettre à chacun de
s'installer pour le prochain point à
l'ordre du jour la séance est
suspendu